foreign
I was actually this close away from
pissing myself I think we had 20
kilometers left where I was really
feeling faint I was like let's just do
it I thought you meant let's just piss
yourself
welcome back to another episode of the
tri-states podcast were we recording
yeah we've been recording oh [__]
I was like can you guys stop talking for
a second Oh I thought we were just uh
[__] we haven't done we haven't done the
audio test yet we did while we were
talking about air conduction oh oh yeah
okay anyway welcome back to another
episode I'm Yours Joey I'm with the boys
as per usual and uh Chris is back yeah
say hi how you doing it's your boy Chris
wait which camera am I looking at
because last time I looked at the wrong
camera for the entire two hours
every time I did like a funny sentence I
was like
is that what you looked that way
oh no that's the middle yeah so don't we
don't really look into them look into
this one it was Landing jokes like a
stage performance off to the side I
actually had to remove the left track
that was their life
anyway it's been what eight nine months
maybe a long time yeah it has been nine
months
my greatest achievement this morning I
nearly like drowned on the way here I
was in a taxi with bakari sweat and the
driver was like
like every mouthful like just
like it's like waterboarding myself on
Wheels father I [__] hate that yeah
but other than that I'm good A bit very
hot and I've just arrived and the guys
are like by the way the air conditioning
doesn't work here it's not that bad it's
a nice it's one of the nicer days the
Studio's gone downhill
there's like a landfill site by the
window yeah that's the rubbish Corner
yeah
we've just accumulated a lot of [__] was
I'm sorry Chris it used to be near the
entrance yeah so now it's in like a
little bit more of an inconspicuous we
thought we'd clean things up for you but
uh you know yeah apparently our efforts
were just not seen just a big pile of
rubbish so there
yeah it's the biggest the biggest thing
is that you move to Tokyo so you're here
now finally yeah
um
I don't know I'm kind of wish I hadn't
come here
it's like seven degrees warmer here than
Sunday it's only like two hours away by
bullet train right but yeah yeah
um it's been good but like getting
around Tokyo is a bit [__] in the summer
like I'm living off of picari sweat my
blood is like 50 for curry and it needs
to be because just drinking water
doesn't do it you need salts why picara
and antioxidants antioxidants not
antioxidants what's the word wait wait I
think that's something that's from the
team from the man that brought you
osmosis
down here in Tokyo every other week for
like yeah something like yeah I mean the
novelty is sort of worn off very fast
given that I used to come to take it so
much anyway yeah it's been good it's
been good to be nearby friends
yeah and like it it's it's cool like
we're just getting the newborn Japan
Studio set um the sets being built next
week and um it's being like doubled in
size you can finally fit my entire yeah
you guys in there yeah but we've got the
Ramen Shop electronics store and now
there's going to be like a 1980s
Japanese living room oh yeah it's nice
because one I think one criticism about
the brawn Japan set is it's very like
cold-hearted like the man that presents
the video it's very like a depressing
Ramen Shop yeah and that's kind of cool
but like well I mean you were kind of
going for like a cyberpunk aesthetic
anyway yeah yeah
and yeah that's gonna be a lot of fun
but I've got a present for you oh
I remember when I moved here an American
colleague always talked about Chile and
I pretended to know what he was talking
about yeah
and then I was chilly right yeah but no
red wine would be complete without a
cheese board of course
a patronizing these small pieces
to cheese microscopic samples you do
need a telescope
all right one for each other foreign
because the other day when we were
hanging out you were talking about this
like brown cheese or something
you remembered it yeah you said to me I
like Norwegian Brown cheese yeah that's
like your new thing now
when Chris and I were hanging out the
other day it's the first thing you said
is like how's it going by the way Brown
cheese actual Banger and I'm like oh
okay he's no longer the camera beer man
anymore he's good Norwegian Brown cheese
Brown in Japan brown shoes I like live
near a Norwegian coffee shop for
whatever reason and um yeah they have
the they have brown cheese on Norwegian
bread I was like I'll try this delicious
food and they brought it out it's
amazing what is it what's cheese is it
reminiscent
I thought it's so good it's kind of like
caramelized cheese
what foods you're gonna like by how
unhealthy they are so unhealthier it is
the more you're like so much
Camembert wasn't bad enough for me you
know how many calories can we pack into
this you know yeah we'll go to like
Yakitori and you know you'll have this
great you know I'm sure he's not it's
not I wouldn't say it's healthy it's not
terrible and of course without failure
it will get and it is [__] good
though we go to this one place and they
have like cheese but of course you'll
get like four
dude that's what happened the other day
when we went drinking at this like
British pub he got two fish and chips to
himself he was supposed to tell anyone
about it oh my God
the efficient fish and chips in Japan a
[__] small size exactly
from that Pub they are good yeah I know
the one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
it's good [__] and uh the fish and chips
was decent I will say it was like a
regular size thing it wasn't like it was
like
just before boxing right it was a simple
time yeah it was November you guys made
a bet about you getting a six-pack yeah
it still hasn't he
live up to his end of the deal and he
still hasn't I did pay it did you
actually I did I did it yeah I'm not a
monster
thank you for cheese you're not you're
not a monster but it's hard to get the
wallet to open up sometimes that this is
his way of repairing him cheese and wine
I I lost the uh six pack bet yeah I was
putting a lot of pressure this what was
the BET what was the bet so it was yeah
let's get a six-pack by the in like six
weeks or something yeah in six weeks by
the time you guys did your cyclophone
right right right
and then you I learned it's a little bit
difficult to get
really
very difficult I [__] up honestly I I
should have tried more for that yes
boxing event there's no two ways about
it but I was under a lot of pressure at
the time I was also writing the damn
book right so I'm like booking one hand
then getting smashed in the face and the
other day oh yeah one of the things
people don't know about the first
cyclathon and the one of the smartest
decisions Chris made was that he was
gonna have a deadline for the book
whilst we were cycling promo so every
night you were like you're stressing out
and then you're like we'd all we you
know if we had a meal we'd go to bed 10
p.m normal time I'd charge my stuff and
go to bed wake up the next day because
oh I went to bed at three like why the
[__] did you go to the bed
so is there one chapter of the book
that's just like really badly written
because you're just suffering from brain
damage
just smashing the keys
cheers
glasses available now on the trash day
store
I feel bad because I wanted to get you a
present Chris I tried really really hard
under what I wonder what guy he's gone
really really hard to win a prize at
Connor's Charity Auction
I watched here in the audience with Sid
going like
I woke up at 10 A.M that morning and I
was like oh [__] I'm missing Connor's
show and I tune in literally seconds
before you started doing the big mouth
thing yeah which went for an astonishing
8 000 don't yeah somehow for something
that was like a dodgy printout that you
guys frame that was a high okay come on
it's fine it's printer quality we framed
it I'll have it I felt like I was framed
like honestly
it went fragrant and that is astonishing
and um
what was your limit uh five grand oh
[__] yeah
damn it seriously it would have been fun
to have given it back to you yeah
through this endless cycle you can't
escape it the groundhog day of abuse
oh my God
[Music]
I can't believe that that was a real
happy ending to the to the story and as
I you know I don't look like big mouth
anymore right I'm metamorously better
yeah I was moving well we're trying to
bring you back don't worry with all this
cheese you know yeah
bring him back to the Glory Days you
know Oblivion show me the show me the
real abroad in Japan but that was good
though it was a good auction and uh yeah
yeah did really well oh yeah yeah very
well
no jokes wow you while you were doing
the big mouth auction do you ate a crack
of from Hell or something we have one
upstairs we no [__] off unless you want
to do it now I'll go one tube challenge
yeah have you ever done it I haven't no
you want to try it no okay I because I
couldn't tell if you were like
deliberately like drawing out to get
more
I think it's like the equivalent of like
two crushed up Carolina Reapers like
funny like 10 mil and that's what you
had on the trash taste 24 hours I had a
ghost pepper which is one level down
from that no it's like two two oh two or
three okay yeah and it was you had that
on a auction it's like yeah two of them
how are you not like physically sick all
over the steps well because I have a
good spice I have a good spice tolerant
but that was that next time that was
really pushing it the worst the worst
time I've ever had it is I was doing the
stream where one of my Pokemon died I
would I would take take one because I
thought I can handle the pepper and the
first one was fine um you know I was I
was in pain but it wasn't terrible but I
think there was some kind of like
follow-up punch that the second one did
okay get that away Navi we don't want to
see that what is this
gave me like a a follow-up punch uh
uh yeah Carolina Reaper pepper Scorpion
Chili Pepper uh so scorpion Chili's the
second most Carolina Reaper all in one
you can smell it if you want I know it's
it's us it's vacuum sealed yes uh do not
eat if you're sensitive to spicy foods
allergic to Peppers nightshades or
pregnant
um yeah I think medical assistance
should you die yeah yeah so I took two
peppers like an hour after each other
and the second one I felt like nearly
put me in a coma it hurt my stomach so
bad to the point where I just couldn't
stream I had to like lie down for 30
minutes and like come back later and be
like sorry guys yeah it's a bold me so
that was dumb and this one wasn't that
bad because I had like a gallon of milk
right right and the milk helped so much
because everyone's like oh the next
day's worse but yeah the next day is
worse if it's not absolutely
encapsulated by one liter of milk so is
that would you say the worst thing
you've had like in terms of spice oh
yeah I think so God damn worst one it
comes in a box shaped like a coffin no
less yeah and that like sets you up
that's marketing yeah the stomach pain
was the worst part near the end of the
auction I was trying to do it did you
did you get the cramps yeah yeah I was
getting the stomach cramps the spicy pea
I did get the spicy do you get that
what's up what a spice toilet habit
have you ever done like the ghost pepper
or like Caroline Reaper challenges or
anything like that no uh on a series of
Gene cross Japan last year with you we
had what was it called what it was
there's some [__] spicy food that
looked like Tar It was supposed to be
the spiciest thing in the world or
something I don't know
yeah
oh we had to have it on a toothpick
right uh the sauce yeah I'd have it on a
toothpick and that might incinerated my
tongue and I was like it was like pure
that's probably pure like capsaicin or
we had that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah why
do people do it I don't know it's just
like dangerous yeah what I've learned is
that like a little toothpick is like
fine because no matter how much you take
it's just not enough to like spread
around your mouth and [__] it all up but
having like the chip or like the noodle
soup like when it's just completely
coating your entire organs those noodles
[__] hurt that's what that's what it
really hurts yeah and it was just like
pain but I think I'm I'm gonna lay off
the spicy stuff for a while
what are the Thai food needs to stay
because when I drink I've become like a
human vacuum when I drink it it's just
like my normal appetite is just like
quadruples when I have like one beer for
me it's not it's not the day I'm getting
drunk It's The Hangover for some reason
when I wake up uh even if I'm on like a
diet if and I go out go drinking have a
like a moderate amount of drink I wake
up and I'm like first thing in the
morning I just crave a McDonald's
breakfast and I don't one's not enough I
have to order two now for me for me yeah
for me for me it's the like right at the
end of the night when I'm when we're
like all right let's go home and we're
heading to the taxi or the station or
whatever and I'm just like no that's
when you've got to fight go for a cheeky
Little Mac when you have to fight you
have to I can't I can't my brain's just
like you need to eat two Big Macs right
now you have to just like okay because
it doesn't feel satisfying right before
you go to bed yeah you just feel like
[__] and then you wake up and you're
like I hate my life today's episode is
sponsored by PayPal honey the easy way
to say save on your iPhone or Computer
Guys inflation am I right
absolutely I can't afford anything
anymore well God thanks to Honey
manually searching for coupon codes
thing of the past Honey's the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best
ones it finds to your card guys the ear
of sad dance over because I've
discovered honey in my life it does feel
so good when you find a good hidden deal
boys you're probably wondering how it
works so imagine you're shopping on one
of your favorite sites okay when you get
to the checkout the honey button appears
and all you have to do is Click apply
coupon wait a few seconds as honey
search for coupons that I can find for
that same and if honey finds a working
coupon you'll watch the prices drop I
came
boys it is summer right now with a lot
of Summer Blockbusters and I saved a
whole five dollars on the latest
Blockbuster releases going to the
theater oh wow that's a steal well
you'll be happy to know God and audience
honey doesn't just work on desktop it
works on your iPhone too just activate
it on Safari on your phone and save on
the go look if you don't already have
honey you could be straight up missing
out everybody getting it I'll be doing
yourself a solid as well as supporting
this show as well so get PayPal honey
for free today at joinhoney.com trash
taste that's joinhoney.com
yes sir thank you PayPal honey for
sponsoring us today back to the episode
speaking of hate
okay something you want to say Chris Los
Angeles oh I've finally been to the City
of Lights wherever it's called I've had
the city of disappointment and lots of
[__] traffic and awful actually the
food's good and the people are good I'll
get I think the people of LA are really
friendly very nice I don't know why
everyone's so surprised it's a little
bit worrying you guys have been there a
lot more than I have I mean I think that
I think a lot of I guess people I
interact with are pretty nice but I get
a very sterilized view of it I suppose
yeah I I mean I like the people that I
know that I mean the content creators
but the general Vibe I get of La is that
it's uh every man for themselves it's
very superficial a lot of ways just like
in and out burger yeah
you have to get the In and Out Burger
dude it's amazing I went there and I got
the french fries no the french fries are
[__] right yeah and then they tasted
like cardboard tastes like something
yeah they have a Bookshop and like I was
like what is this a lot of people praise
the chips they're like you you got the
wrong fries dude they're around
burger restaurant you just want fries I
don't want like the secret special order
well yeah I think because the fries are
just so bad what's it got to be animals
animals but the the reason why I guess
it's it's kind of revered is that it's
like you can get the double burger for
like what five bucks so it's like a
really good price for a solid body yeah
because like you you know obviously it's
not as good as like five guys but Five
Guys is like five times the price I mean
Five Guys is basically restaurant prices
they charge a ridiculous amount and then
those fries yeah those Cajun Friesian
fries man fish yeah they're all good
yeah it was a really trippy City when I
did the chess boxing I stayed in
downtown L.A
after you know a long 12 hour flight
whatever it is and like yeah there was
just a man running naked down the middle
of the road going and I was like yep
hello yeah yeah sounds about right Skid
Row uh near it I was staying I think two
or three blocks of it oh God you know
that's right that's right
yeah there's definitely a lot of issues
going on there but but um yeah I know
God's been wanting to grill me on the
chess boxing I'm gonna see a cliff have
gone like I was so disappointed in Chris
I feel like I let you down gone you you
didn't let me down I was it I you know I
got tilted for you you know like you
know we you know I was tuning into the
chess boxing to cheer on my bro cheer on
my man and you were doing so well you
had this point where you're about to win
and then you had a point where you could
have like checkmated or ended the game
and then you threw away your queen
it's literally the worst mistake you
literally you literally went from a
winning position to uh throwing away
your queen and I was just like what the
[__] up yeah this is really annoying in
the chess boxing fight like the the
real-time chessboard that all the
viewers everyone was watching is kind of
broken yeah yeah we'll see what I was
doing a little bit behind I was the
first two rounds I was doing really well
like I pinned the queen yeah and I was
being really fast and my tactic was to
try and move really quickly and get like
a minute ahead yeah and by the second
round of Chess that's where I was at but
like I sort of shot myself with the foot
because every one who I told that I was
doing the boxing stuff they were like
everyone has a plan so they get punched
in the face I was like [__] off I think
I know what I'm doing and then I got hit
in the face very hard on the on the
second round I got hit in the face and
have you ever been hit in the face yeah
yeah you probably have yeah
your brothers
I have actually yeah huh where uh at a
house party when I was uh 18 years old
yeah I just I got just got in a fight uh
with uh someone was like really really
[__] drunk and just looking for a
fight uh
group of them started on a few mates of
mine uh and then one of them threw a
punch and then just a fighting suit and
that's the only fight I've ever been a
part of and uh yeah that's good that's
good yeah how did it feel would you
enjoy it didn't feel great
yeah I had to you after that I was like
you know what maybe being a monk is a
bad thing I have no enemies actually
this is overrated
uh but yeah that was like I remember the
first time getting punched in like
getting probably punched in the face and
this was like not even in a controlled
environment this was just straight up
just getting punched in the face uh you
you have that you know at the moment
like you you basically get stun locked
you're just like you feel it and then
you don't feel the pain you just feel
like the shock of it happening too yeah
you got the adrenaline in Russia you
just I just remember being punched in
the face and I just like holy holy [__]
what the [__] just happened it's like
it's like the flashbanging code yeah
yeah exactly
you just like stun looks I I know I
never forgot that feeling of like being
punched for the first time because he's
just like you know you forget like what
just happened you're like oh I just got
punch in the face yeah and then you
start punching back I mean it only
happened to me when I was 14. I was
making fun of some guy's bike it was the
most mundane fight some guy turned up
who I hated and he had a bike called a
mongoose Pro and I was like mate your
bike's [__] he's like what did you say
like Mongoose and he punched me and that
was that was the only fight I had had
pre 30 years old
and so I yeah I when I
buy some shoes
did you punch him back or I did punch
you back yeah that Mongoose Pro bike
what a villains Mongoose prayer side uh
yeah so I signed up the chest boxing
because Conor made me do it
I never I said you wouldn't do it
was like yeah you want to do it bro I
was like yeah right and that was the
main reason just to spike on and also
part of the fitness channel
yeah and honestly like the boxing
training was relentless and great but I
I was training with Nick and I you've
met Nick you guys learned it he's uh he
he was in the boxing rig he's kind of
like oh okay okay oh yeah he's a former
K1 kickboxing champion right of Japan he
fought like in the in the Tokyo dome in
the early 2000s and it was watched by
like 50 million people yeah he's a real
celebrity but he is like Gaston out of
the enemies in the Beast his arms are
like without the baggage hopefully yeah
he eats like a thousand eggs a day his
arms are like the size of Spain and
they're massive and if he hits you as he
did training like we so I would spy with
him a few times a week
um and he hit me in the face and like
everything just sort of went white for a
second it was a really scary yeah it was
[__] scary because I've never been
I've never had that before and it wasn't
even a big hit by his standards but
again when he's super trained to do this
yeah
I'm gonna hit you now you're ready I was
like yeah I'm ready
I was like whoa I'm actually quite
scared now it's like you know when you
get hit like that your whole brain sort
of rocks a little bit yeah this white
flash which is something I'd never
experienced before I I've never had that
white flash
concussion
[Laughter]
I so I never had that and I was like oh
what the [__] have I done at this point
it was like November
did you want to like it was probably
back out but I was like has maybe this
was a bad decision
having no actual experience yeah but I
was against that German dude
yeah and then while he was training and
I I always thought I could take him he
was a bit taller than me it was quite
skinny yeah um and I think we would have
been on par with chess or maybe he would
have been a little bit better on chess
but then he burst his eardrum train yeah
somebody hit him in the ear ear got
blown up and he was like I can't fight
now yeah
um who I was going against and here to
pull out for other health reasons so
it's just like God doesn't want me to
fight I think it's pretty common though
that a lot of these these events are
like 50 of the fighters or not a little
less than that but end up pulling out
for concussions yeah whatever it is just
because yeah and there was a video up to
that one like yeah there's a lot of
people we pulled out and uh so I was
like oh maybe God let me off the hook
here and then like don't worry we've
brought in a black belt in Jiu Jitsu I
was like brilliant yeah it was very I
got stitched up like a villain
you came out I saw after the fact but
because obviously I was up there with
you but everyone was like rip rip Chris
did you see
yeah I did watch it back so I came out
with um uh Nick and Pete and Connor were
cheering and I was like yeah you know I
was like hey is like [__] 50 000
people there 500 000 watch online it was
really cool moment actually that was
like the highlight of like last year for
me yeah look at that walkout and then I
I was really cocky I was like I got a
box of Hershey's and smashed it over my
leg and threw it into the crown
and then he came he comes out to some
like [__] terrifying soundtrack from
like a horror film so like sirens and
then I yeah I saw that there was a poll
and it was like is Chris gonna die
he's obviously someone who had uh you
know worked out and had Fitness as a
huge part of his life yeah yeah so
obviously you know as for me as a viewer
watching it with twitch chat like like
there were a lot of abroad and Japan
fans in chat cheering you on you came
out first and everyone's like yo
everyone's like being supportive the
hope was high it's like you got it and
then there was just like one [__]
shot of your opponent walking out and I
think there was just a collective oh
[__] oh [__] well it's been a good run
boys get the body bag ready
we were actually a similar way he was
he's a bit taller and he had big arms
but because my legs are like tree trunks
you know my muscles in my legs which is
not overly useful I'm fast as [__] boy
might have been a different thing yeah
but uh yeah but I was still like
yeah and then we had the chess match the
first round and it was going really well
I was I was really up on time which is
my strategy I was like if I [__] my
queen which I actually thought I might
under stress at least I'd be like a
minute up right yeah and then I went to
the first match and he and it's just
really weird it's really hard to explain
what it's like being in a ring with 20
000 people whatever it was around but
like you you forget they're all there
because the bright lights are on your
face and all you can see is him and in
between you can sort of see in the
distance Conor and the audience going
like that because I can see every
shoulder but like yeah just this moment
where I saw him like focusing on me
about to hit me and I was like what the
[__] have I done
what is this like I really Stitch myself
up when past self really [__] me like
when you when you're looking at someone
you're like I'm about to get hit in
front of like half a million people yeah
like that's what it's like what have I
done like the moments later cocky
[__] her she's throwing it into the
crowd and now it's like I could like get
knocked out or die in front of everyone
you think you're just not like uh was
that like a weird thing for you to have
to do to like lock on to someone and be
like I gotta punch this guy yeah because
when I was training with Nick we didn't
really Spa properly yeah we were hitting
each other but I never had a and this is
my fault I didn't put enough time into
it I really didn't train that much with
the boxing as much as I should have yeah
trained on the fitness front right for
stamina yeah and I suppose that's one
good thing in the chest box I survived I
made it to round three yeah it takes so
much energy to keep moving and dodging
and blocking throwing punches and um but
I had never fought anyone before really
and I couldn't fight Nick because he was
too big and I could not have won so that
was really my first actual fight
sparring practice or not yeah it was a
spectacular error a lot of the other uh
YouTubers whatever that did it that I
really went for it that I had at least
enjoyed it and really liked it were like
yeah sparring was everything like if
they they would use like so much and
that really allowed them to kind of get
a lot better at boxing and I think being
like you mentioned just have been
prepared to be beaten up yeah it seems
like a hard thing to do and uh you know
that's why a lot of people get injured
yeah
but I'm the sort of person that's always
like ah I do the homework tomorrow
but in that first match when he locked
on and he got that first punch I got
really stunned yeah and I was like oh my
God it didn't look like when he landed
the first hit on you that you were like
oh [__] I'm gonna I gotta figure
something out yeah yeah and the plan was
basically trying to keep avoiding or
blocking yeah I mean honestly legitimate
strategy if you know you're not gonna be
able to outbox him yeah
I mean he clearly had experience but so
the second round of Chess I started
moving up and I actually had a plan of
attack blocked his queen and I was like
always King rather and I was like I
could actually win this wrap this up in
the second round right and then it got
to the end of the second round and I was
two three moves away from executing the
plan and then time was up and I was like
No And then I went back in the
battlefield absolutely obliterated and
punched in the face over and over and by
the time I came back I was like oh
because your heart's going like yeah
yeah your head's a bit like and like I
sort of just went uh that one's there
and I [__] did the wrong
they're wrong
ful just boxing right so you have to
manage all that stress level yeah but if
you watch it luckily I don't go
oh because I still felt like I might be
able to win because I looked at the
timer and there was a minute up and it's
another thing that's really weird you're
wearing the headphones right yeah so you
can't hear they don't really help that
much they don't help you're listening to
[__] Beethoven while you're having a
stroke because it's like I'm having a
heart attack a stroker listen to
Beethoven all at once while playing
chess and getting beaten up when I was
wearing them I could easily hear the
crowds exactly and I could hear like the
moment I [__]
before he even retaliated I think
everyone went
and I was like no but and then in the
third round I got really angry and went
a bit aggressive but yeah I I think the
thing with the chest boxing I feel like
I didn't deserve to win after I
blundered the queen maybe it's the wrong
way of looking at it I did win after all
um and there were some major mistakes
like the chessboard was set up wrong
when I started yeah I was like and go
and I was like and I moved and I I think
I [__] up I made like an illegal move
because the horse was in the wrong
Square the horse and the bishop were in
the wrong [__] place
and then he started making some illegal
moves and it all went to [__] a little
bit but yeah it was It was kind of weird
because then I guess the illegal move
allowed them to have time to kind of
think and then yeah it was really
bizarre it was yeah I guess they just
didn't expect the chess level to be that
bad where people would just be making
illegal moves yeah
yeah I mean you kept you cool after you
blundered the queen yeah yeah that's
that's the important thing in chess I
guess did you do any chess practice I
did do a fair bit of Chess yeah okay it
was cool actually I was like one day
I'll be training boxing training yeah uh
at my friend's gym over in like a Yorkie
Parker and then the next day I'd be like
in New York park with the chest train
and we're playing in the park and stuff
it was a really cool one time actually I
think was kind of like spread between
chess and boxing and then writing a book
and it was really really weird kind of
three four months which is why like no
videos I can't train to not blunder
though yeah yeah
at every level as well like even like
the grand Masters sometimes blunder
pieces well in the last week before
training when I was doing chess they
made me like run for like 30 seconds
really intense then sit down and play oh
my God it changes the game oh I can
imagine yeah you know when your heart's
racing yeah yeah really good experience
don't regret doing it we'll look back on
it and go wow but I don't think I want
to get hit in the face again no more
boxes you're going out as a champ yeah
yeah
The Undefeated Champion the chess boxing
champion why not you know but I I think
I might carry on the boxing training
without this
yeah yeah so I actually felt like I
could defend myself in a way that I
never could perform before last year
yeah you know was it like in the
dressing room beforehand were you like
nervous uh yeah when did it like hit you
it hit me there's a the Stadium's there
right right and we had a suite or a room
upstairs and you were there in a few
yeah
I came in and out
that's because Chris was in like the
zone and Nick was like I was talking to
you like you're about to [__] go on a
Navy Seals raid and they were so in the
zone that I was like I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna let him do the thing yeah
yeah because Nick was like don't you
[__] dare talk to him don't you dare
talk be nice too and I was like
I don't think enough space to talk to
your opponent I get it I get it because
I guess if it's more like you don't even
want to have an ounce of sympathy when
you're trying to punch the game yeah of
course but also at the end of the day I
was like I think it's just a fun Little
Rock well that was a weird thing
actually because I did talk to my
opponent um over at Floyd PJ beforehand
and like he humanized him a bit I saw
he's a real American person and I was
like so when I'm fighting him I'm like I
don't actually dislike this guy why do I
have to hit him
he's like [__] like that down there
like it's really weird you know he's
like I am going to kill this man yeah
but
hit me when I was in that room looking
down right I did have like a small like
Panic attacking moment I was like what
the [__] have I done why would you do
this yourself it's like you know going
oh yeah I'll put my feet in a blender no
problem and then like the day arrives
the blender's there and you're like ah
actually I don't know
core memory they're saying you'll never
ever forget and you can always talk
about it like it's those kind of stuff
that I think that you can always look
back on and be like I'm it was maybe
stupid or maybe crazy but I'm glad I did
it honestly I'm really lucky that I did
come out without a serious injury
with uh concussions reporting that
they're they feel slower still about
months after yeah it's pretty scary
that's why I don't know if I could
advise anyone to do it really I don't
think it is worth the risk because if
you brain damage yourself get concussion
I could have written off half of this
year if it had gone really bad yeah I
think a lot of people really struggle to
comprehend if they're healthy and
they're fit that they could ever be
injured severely and have like a be
punching ahead and then you just
actually just cognitively worse offer it
I think it's really hard for people to
think about that future self of them
like think about that and they're just
like it's a cool opportunity I want to
get punched it's like well hold on now
let's really let's really look into this
and see is this actually worthwhile yeah
think about the long term like if you
came out of this yeah maybe you win it's
great you got fit you got the victory
it's great for you but like what if you
you got beaten the [__] up you have you
have a concussion that could that sticks
with you for life because when you have
one concussion you have a higher chance
of getting another concussion yeah and
then who knows what kind of damage
you've given yourself could be slower in
some ways you just don't expect could
have taken five years off your life
maybe you just don't know like what kind
of dance like that that could give you I
mean the brain is the one thing you
don't want to [__] around with yeah
absolutely I have a lot more respect for
Fighters though the discipline it takes
to do all that you know I do have a lot
of respect for people to do it I don't
know why they do it necessarily maybe
it's that Rush there was a real rush in
the ring no I could definitely see this
at that carnal Rush yeah yeah it was
pretty [__] cool in the ring knowing
all eyes are on you for this moment what
you're about to do nothing I've never
had a feeling like that ever yeah even
being up on stage doing other things
I've never felt like that yeah that was
really good that I think is the
sensation they lock onto
yeah I mean from how you describe it it
definitely can feel like it could be an
addicting feeling
um personally I respect for you for
saying yes uh I don't know if I could
ever do that
I'm good I like one year ago I would
have been like no I'm not doing that I
was like the right set of ingredients it
took a bad Health Report it took the
objective like you know
Connor's abuse
it took like I before even new chess
boxing was a thing you know I was like
I'm gonna be the fittest I've ever been
by the end this year so when Ludwig
brought it up and Conor brought it up it
was like okay this is the one way to
make this happen I was just looking
vicariously through you because I wish I
could do it well you did get slapped in
the face yeah yeah it's fine it's you
know it's not the same that was more of
like a WWE performance then yeah it was
pretty than a actual fine yeah I mean it
definitely hurt a little bit but he was
going easy on me and I was getting a
little easy on him he definitely needs
you on me that's because I told him like
two minutes before I was like by the way
I've got a blood condition don't hit me
down
well because it was a slap and I knew he
wasn't we weren't trying to hurt each
other because there was no way that you
could lose via the slap right because
the idea was that it was just the chess
thing yeah and then give yourself a
concussion before the chess thing you
wouldn't get a concussion from being
slapped unless so they went full like
full well like like one of those like
[__] voice critical videos yeah but
that's like
they turn around to the camera and their
face is just full yeah well that's
that's more than a concussion concussion
is the last thing they're worrying about
in that situation that's like playing
like [__] fear at home it's like oh
am I actually going to come out of this
ring with the same face like that's the
thing they're worrying about it just
becomes like a bowling ball yeah oh my
God I've seen some of those things yeah
and now you're fitter for it yeah you're
eating now you're kind of going back
have you found like so you've done like
this yeah so this podcast is brought to
you by cash app with tools for saving
and spending it's the best place for you
to level up your money and glow up your
life guys as you know I'm a real gamer
okay sure I play jrpgs unlike any good
jrpg to get to the end game you gotta
grind and level up on your stats and
that includes all of your stats like
your finances preach speaking of Finance
is gone you still owe me money and
thanks to cash app to pay someone it's
easy all you need is their phone number
or their email or their cash tag So Gone
even you you can pay me back and that
doesn't move you gone I can even scan a
QR code straight from your app so that
you can pay me you'll see your balance
updated immediately so you always know
when a payment went through from
security locks to data encryption cash
app uses Advanced features to keep you
and your money safe browse topics find
resources or chat with a human cash app
support has answers to all your
questions not only that you can save on
everyday spending get exclusive and
exclusive discounts with the cash R pay
and cash cards cash up allows you to
bank the way that you want a faster
simpler way to bank without so many fees
so if you want to level up your life you
want to level up your money so download
cash app in the app store Google Play
with the link in description down below
with no hidden fees and a free to order
debit card it feels like a cheat code
for your finances back to the episode
yeah you've done like the Spartan Race
you've done the chest boxing have you uh
relapsed uh oh yeah
I mean it's yeah everyone's been like
Chris every video I put out people like
analyze it they're like has he put a
weight or not in the comments like Chris
looks great or Chris looks marginally
faster again oh [__] you know I've been
[__] whatever I do I do I think I put
on a little bit more weight because I
haven't been doing all but you're way
you're way better than yeah yeah yeah
yeah absolutely feel a lot fitter and
like when I did the cycle the second
cycle with Connor like I I hadn't
trained for three months yeah the
stamina was still there yeah and the
Spartan Race a few weeks ago and I was
able to get through that and the next
week climbing [__] Mount Fiji again
which I haven't never thought I would do
but um doing that again you're dressing
right for the occasion this time not
going in [__] sure not sleeping on a
rock I'm gonna rock I think I just need
to have the air ambulance on speed dial
because nasty natsuki's gonna do it
right oh [__] he's 50. we will be August
9th as he likes to say my birthday
Nagasaki bomb because uh he always tells
me that it's a great way to remember
when his birthday is for better or worse
but uh yeah he's been cycling because I
I'm like are you actually gonna climb
Mount Fuji that's he's like yeah no
problem it's like you can't go up the
stairs
he because he smokes like 30 40
cigarettes a day yeah 20 cigarettes a
day minimum right his lungs just cannot
be operational yeah and like that's
right it's like oh there's less oxygen
here and what's gonna happen but he has
been cycling every day 40 kilometers oh
damn that's not bad providing he's not
lying I'm encouraged do you think he's
I watched him cycle for 10 minutes and
he did look quite wrecked by the end of
it maybe he's like today only four
kilometers
there's that saying right A wise man
climbs Mount Fuji once a bell end climbs
it twice
in Japanese you'll know it what
the record
a wise man climbs about Fuji once claims
it twice
it's my own contemporary take on it
right yeah
British translation for Japan and the
reason is because it's not a fun climb
it's a big black volcanic Wasteland up
there there's no like almost nice
scenery there's crowds of people the
wind is bad the temperature goes from
hot to freezing yeah and it's just not
really fun
um but people do it obviously for that
once in a lifetime view of the sun
coming up which you can't get from
anywhere else apparently oh from
literally anywhere yeah yeah a wise man
climbs Fuji once only a fool claims it
twice why apparently that's the same
okay I mean I guess it makes sense
because yeah it's but the thing is it's
not actually translated correctly from
the Japanese one the Japanese one is
you're a full if you don't climb Mount
Fuji once you're also a fool if you
climb it twice okay okay one and done
just do it once yeah just do it one and
die so I'm not a fool right now zero
zero is full one is fine saving it so
you're the only one that's not a fool
right I'm not a fool but I will be what
if it's three times did you just go back
to normal again it's like every other
time it's like you're an idiot you're
fine you're an idiot you're fine a
legend
I think we [__] cycled up like four
Foods in uh in uh when we were doing the
Kyushu cycle that was quite possibly
wait so why are you climbing up Fuji
again
[Music]
than an air ambulance oh it's Mount Fuji
um and also to kind of promote the book
because the book cover uh has like Fuji
on the front yeah
it's a book about Japan exactly right
there's no other way
um and uh
yeah I I'm gonna try and do like a book
signing the summit Mount Fuji water
stains have sent me like a banner right
British bookstore if there goes in and
I'm gonna stand there with a pile of
books yeah just hand them out to anyone
who'll take pretty much yeah please
books can you carry up there well I've
got like you know they'll be ASCII you
can carry it yeah four books is even
like heavy you're like that's oh I have
my luggage meal
in all of Japan in the same way Pete
comes on the cycles for the back rubs
natsuki's coming to carry my books I
need I need this that's the reason he's
gonna have an air ambulance right it's
not a mountain it's not books but broken
back yeah just a broker they shipped to
the top could you ship it today
yeah Yamato guy up there you go like air
ambulance to the top
there are some weird things to talk
about food there's vending machines very
cool I'll take some of the magic away
it's like wow that's ethereal Mountain
it's been here for a hundred million
years
you get to the top you're like I'm
parched it's a vending machine
like it's like it's like if you were
stuck in the Oasis in a desert and then
you you know you come along this you're
like oh I need
some water and then Over the Horizon you
just see like a [__] picari sweat
machine you'd be like oh yes and then
you have no coins
just just imagine the guy like refills
that every day yeah he must be the
fittest
yeah right just be like oh you got to go
refill it can you take these off by the
way just leave them up there yeah you
know how there's like in every kung fu
movie that's like a secret like Grand
Master that's like training in the
mountains it's just the [__] guy
bring up the pukary school man's
definitely taking up the senzu
there's something worse than that when
you get to the fifth station which is
the typical starting point for the climb
yeah there's a shop that sells cans of
air from the summit of mountains so
there's literally someone whose job is
to go up to the summit be like
and then walk down again
from the summer actually tried buying
one of those like it wasn't even one of
the cans it was literally a plastic bag
right so someone had gone up to the top
of Mount Fuji just went and just like
tied in a plastic bag and a thousand yen
please I could make a profit from this
trip
and then I'll use the bags to bag the
air yeah
it's the book with inside a bag with the
air of the summer imagine my face when I
get when I go to the door for a delivery
one day I open it the postman gives me
like well it feels like an empty box I
open it and it's just a [__] bin bag
you try to open the bin bag it's like
what is it rip lose that precious hair
what a weird Mountain but like I've seen
photos of the crowns this year and it is
a joke because it's the first year I
think it's properly officially open so
it's right outside world and it looks
like the world's biggest theme park
right there's photos of at night right
where everyone using lights you can see
Fuji and then the top third there's a
sneaking line of lights no and it's just
like oh God but Ace up my sleeve good
friend of mine Victor frame of travel
you guys know yes uh he climbed Mount
fuja every year see the summit I thought
he did it in one day and I was like
Victor you're a God have you done this
but he doesn't like six days which is I
think which is smart yeah and much more
mad I think so maybe it's three or five
but he
he's like there's a secret path around
the back and there's like four trails at
Mount Fuji and he's told me to go up
this secret one where we'll probably get
eaten by
no one secret now yeah everyone it's a
sheer Cliff this episode will probably
come out after the climb forever but
don't come up the secret Trail but yeah
we're gonna get moved by bear instead
yeah there's gonna be no one there but I
think this secret Trail and I'll give
you a secret Trail Secrets he's got 25
the footfall of the main route right and
but it's a little bit steeper and it's
supposed to be the hardest way which is
why it's the secret it's not so much
this is why no one goes in Japan you've
made a video on that yeah it's not so
much the secret route as the death rate
because it's like a vertical [__]
climb I have a volcanic it's free
climbing up until they've done quicker
if we survive yes they'll find my co-ops
a lot quicker but uh yeah it is what it
is Christmas corpse and all around them
is just his books
Forever on the side of Mount feet
it's going to collect them well speaking
of book of book oh book that's the sort
of grammar you can expect of single book
I do have a copy from smack when I go on
trash day so I take my belt off wow
she's official chips they'd sit down for
like three hours do you have another two
portions anyway
that cover is so clean by the way it's
nice I was Mr affable there before that
I was no not last year Barry Chopsticks
very Chopsticks
this year best-selling author Sunday
Times best-selling author Barry
Chopsticks and let me check if yep
that's for you guys thank you so much
Chris
10 years in the Land of the Rising Sun I
could only carry like one book oh I
already got mine oh my God
you can get yours at the top of my mouth
next Wednesday midday
signed by the author you can get yours
at the website
it's signed it'll be worth at least
three pounds one day oh great yeah you
can it's because it's got the author
signature in it you can sell it for more
sure so so kind of so it kind of wins
when when's your next Charity Auction
[Laughter]
one [__] up with the book
oh yeah so obviously I read every six
months it's gone off right you don't
just sit down and Bash our book in a
weekend yeah well I tried oh this is
Stephen King
I just opened up and I opened up to
chapter five Mr dick
oh my God a literature Masterpiece
brought in Japan Mr dick when I read
chapter Mr Dick I was left in tears
the big [__] up I I wrote the chapters
in a rush and then I saw penguin cycling
no I thought yeah because I was so big
with you and I thought penguin would be
like let's just check the chapter they
didn't they just literally kept in the
ones I was like well we'll think about
the chapter later so look at the chapter
list page the front many [__] snow
that's a nastyism right there let me uh
all right read out these chapter names
all right let me see chapter one Sushi
Revelation the Japan lottery sweet and
San hot springs and tiny cars Mr Dick
sake onigashimasu
[Laughter]
uh when teaching goes wrong many [__]
snow The Impossible language
it's party time after that
keep up on the language go party that's
like I've done my work here all right
the Land of the Rising waistline
uh all right Hostess clubs and the Art
of expensive companionship okay get out
now uh that's a good chapter all right
uh Japan's most eccentric man the wise
men of Fuji Doctor Who uh I believe
that's uh
oh Jesus Christ okay yes again the BBC
won't be calling it's all right uh fried
uh Fried Chicken addicted bear the worst
possible start a letter from the colonel
saying goodbye can you guess what that's
about to see I I when I got my first KFC
Christmas bucket yeah because you get
Christmas in Japan right yeah you open
it up and it's just a left it's like a
letter from the colonel I'm like well
let it from Colonel somewhere you flip
it over it's like put it in the
microwave it's literally the letter from
the colonel put the [__] chicken in the
microwave and then saying goodbye
starting over Cat Nation a home at last
missiles incoming grounds it what were
we living
[Applause]
uh seeking redemption in a lost year
disappearing Kyoto this is my dream fear
and earthquake Chris I don't see a
chapter about meeting trash tasters
book part two acknowledgment
acknowledgments Are We There are we in
the acknowledgment section at least
wow that's a good book you should
definitely yeah I've got one yeah where
can they buy us
Amazon's water stones whatever all major
book retailers it's not all right well
it will be I think when this comes out
but it wasn't on Amazon us because they
like penguin are like we'll see it
because it's penguin UK
Bill book Bill a book deal in America
right and I was like sure so they didn't
I don't think they did and then they
just they released it themselves but it
meant when I was promoting the book
there was nothing on Amazon Us by the
time they were working out and somebody
when this [__] cover was released
somebody screenshotted it put it under
an account called like Todd lb and
people started buying the fake abroad in
Japan book oh [__] so they would get
this and it's like a really crappy that
7-Eleven print job yeah open it up and
inside the book
was a technical guide for breastfeeding
because you learned that in July it's
like well if that was just the first
edition what
what I learned in Japan chapter one
secrets to breastfeeding I was just like
I got these really sad like Instagram
messages people like I was really
excited to get your book why was it
about breastfeeding
that is the secret of Japan but we got
that book taken down now so don't you
have any [__] thoughts about getting
them yeah don't do that but I don't know
I wanted the only thing I want now is to
be a Sunday Times bestseller so I can
have it you just said you were well and
I don't think we are yet because why are
you claiming you're a Sunday Times best
well we might be if people buy the book
you could just keep saying I can't say
I'm a New York Times bestseller in 20
years but I'm gonna make the book
well yeah oh I see why you wanted to
come on now after like eight months oh I
see lots of promos
well you will get the Sunday Times
bestseller nickname if you actually
become it you know yeah what will the
nickname be until then you're still very
jobs Barry Chopsticks best
of the breastfeeding Guru I don't know I
just feel like I'm uh when you meet me
it's very underwhelming I should
probably sell myself better
hello I have a YouTube channel and like
when you go to a networking event
anywhere if you're in La you're [__]
you have to be like you have to say all
the incredible things you've done like
really fast in 20 seconds and but like
when I meet people I'm like yeah I have
a YouTube channel but now I could be
like yes I'm a Sunday Times New York
Times best-selling author if someone
tells me that I'm just gonna think
they're a bit probably yeah Mr Dick
how should I introduce myself when I
meet people what do you say me yeah uh
I'm from Wales in it well uh Wales is
most famous
was his most mediocre twitch streamer
uh I say go with twitch streamer now I
go with you I just go online personality
all right so maybe we don't say you're
an influencer I don't know
say I say General online personality and
they're like what does that mean I'm
like well if you know you know cycling
cycling
yeah I was like do you like auctions
what do you say get on say I talk about
anime for a living talk about anime that
yeah well I guess that works what do you
say I say I say anime no I say CEO of a
fashion brand CEO of a fashion that's
that's worse than best selling off
they're both Justice pretentions
[__] the CEO I'm a CEO of a broad
Japan industry
that's what you can say someone tells me
they're a CEO I immediately think you're
an idiot
when people say it it's like it's if you
because most of you have to introduce
himself see you I feel like a lot of the
time
well yeah they don't say the word see
yeah
unless they're like really help
themselves
immediately says I'm a CEO I'm like yeah
of what yeah anything I'm like yeah you
might as well just put entrepreneur
yeah yeah I think people realize that
entrepreneurs are bad taste in a lot of
people's mouths yeah yeah
because CEO is now the big hot wood that
everyone is like oh I know I'm just
really bad at saying myself because I
don't want to go too far that's a
British thing though isn't it yeah I
think it's the British we just don't we
just [__] and I go to La and the first
sentence is oh yeah hi I'm this I've
done this I've done this it is weird
when I talk to people and they're like
really proud about what they do yeah and
I'm like why are you why are you proud
I'm like hi I watch cartoons and uh
that's uh
about the stuff we do in LA everyone I
spoke to was like yeah I'm writing a
script for a movie that Steven Spielberg
looked at once five years ago and it's
like oh wow great yeah and like everyone
really put like pushes themselves yeah
and in the UK I feel like you just sound
like a douchebag if you say you've done
anything yeah yeah so it's kind of like
you could literally have like cured
cancer and they were like everyone like
I [__] off Barry right off Chopsticks
what are you [__] doing oh go stop
with another character mate that's why I
just I I [__] hate networking yeah
it's like it's like speed dating for
your ego so you're like you go there and
you're just like let me inflate my ego
as much as possible and see all these
inflated egos well the most important
people often are the ones that have to
desperately be like I've done this I've
yeah good cancer and built a rocket out
of salmon and you're like
yeah I when I'm at Network even I
remember I was one of the UK years ago
five years six years ago yeah way
through the career and uh I was like oh
you know I do YouTube videos and he went
oh yeah
well I'm sort of look past me and it's
just like ah [__] this yeah it sort of
just looks away and takes a flip and
they're looking past you they're trying
to find someone else to bounce off too
yeah so I don't know what what can I
what can I call myself what can I say I
think being a YouTuber is fine yeah I
think I think it's getting selling
author YouTuber you can you can you can
tack that on top of no I think the
best-selling author will work against
the YouTuber title it'll come off as bad
yeah I think you should just mention
your YouTuber and then just mention like
it should naturally come up in
conversation you know because
best-selling author kind of gives the
vibe that you're doing I'm desperate
I want the title buy the book I am
desperate I'm desperate of course you
are whatever I've done nothing nothing I
mean
the chest boxes that's how you can say
you're like I'm
an undefeated chess boxing champion yeah
there you go yeah there you go yeah I
don't know it's one of those things and
like even some people spot me around
Tokyo as happens quite a lot now
Victorious yeah you know somebody met me
I was out waiting outside of uh you
might have been Shibu station today and
so on you um
you were born in Japan I went I think so
it's like even I like trying to be
humble because you're gonna be like yeah
of course I [__] out mate yeah even
that that British like weird humble
networking thing yeah that extends to
like people people run into me yeah you
know I'm like oh I think I'm I think I'm
abroad in Japan yeah whenever whenever
someone comes out to me they're like are
you the anime I'm just like no
and then but then sometimes I guess they
don't they don't see the the irony in it
so I remember this one dude was just
like are you the anime man and I was
like no and he's like oh okay he just
walked off I felt so bad I'm like no no
I'm just kidding I'm scared I I did that
literally two weeks ago yeah
I'm uh no and then he went he sort of
looked like he'd broken he was like
before and stood there for a moment and
I was like I was like this guy looks
like he's gonna die yeah uh no idea
there's more fans recognizing you and no
honestly it's not so much being
approached it's how you approach me yeah
yeah you go Chris I brought your book up
like you're my best friend
basically if they've uh spent money
then uh they're your best [__]
friends you've bought the everyone Japan
book and you've tangible I mean I'll be
nicer than someone if they're like oh
I've subbed you on Twitch so I'm like oh
you actually [__] watch my stuff yeah
yeah yeah like a lot of people see it
and they're like I don't really know but
I think you're famous yeah yeah I think
if people approach me and they they
clearly know who I am then that's fine
it's cool like it's good right I feel
like you're watching or you're meeting a
villa yeah there are times when people
are like you're the YouTube guy right
like oh is it like squeegee fish market
for years ago you're like your YouTuber
you're a Dave in Japan I was like who
the [__] is no no I'm not and like but
I've had people go you're like famous
for something I was with you literally a
few months ago having a barbecue or
something
so we just yeah we went to this one spot
and I I was like a it's like a what was
it called it was in um one of the one of
the Sukiyaki places yeah and we sit down
it's going pretty well for the first
like 10 minutes we're just chatting and
it is roasting though it was
unbelievably hot in that restaurant let
me just turned the AC on and a group of
four white guys sit down and there's
always I think that moment I think in
our heads where we're like we did look
at each other
yeah there's a lot of you know if you're
if you're an English-speaking tourist
odds are you've probably watched chances
of videos yeah I'm gonna take this off
in case
um and so we kind of thought I wonder
and then it was very obvious pretty
quickly that at least two of them of the
four group had recognized yeah yeah and
then it became really awkward because
the two of them were trying to talk
about it and explain to the other two
and then this one other one of those
whose friends is just so annoying he
goes really loudly in this restaurant he
goes like
man they're just YouTubers man they're
not they're real people like really
maybe look to you I think he has a
podcast or something yeah yeah he was
like yeah right but like they were
literally like it's like this distance
it was just like we saw went stalkered
for us because we're like yeah just
really came off as rude yeah I was um
you know I I don't mind it but I was out
with I was surfing with um Felix right
right that's the thing one one the last
times before that his son was born and
um there was two people like a two for a
foreign couple basically like swimming
in the sea nearby and you could tell
they kind of recognized him and were
sort of lingering there and we got out
they they got out and we got out shortly
after a drink and without saying
anything like oh my God Felix what are
you doing here all that man I've loved
the videos they just they just charged
everyone can we have a photo and like
Phoenix was like no and like and like I
was like fair enough you know because
like he didn't say anything I think his
policies just don't take photos yeah I
think a good point because like when
you're that famous yeah it's gonna
happen you're gonna get mobbed but like
I that's sort of interaction I hate
people come over this I need to get a
photo he didn't say anything yeah
there's no like conversation there's no
conversation there you know that and
it's like and it's like and you don't
know whether they're like you know like
they actually really like your content
or they just recognized you from the
internet so yeah I got the impression
that maybe they just recognize it yeah
yeah yeah
you have a moment where you're just like
I don't know if you see me as just like
an object you know where it's just like
hey I get you watch my stuff but you
know yeah we are we are human beings
start a conversation with me yeah yeah
yeah if you're gonna come up yeah that's
the determining fact so if you ever run
into us start a conversation and just be
you know just treat us like I'm rushing
then yeah unless it's an IRL stream that
Conor's doing yeah down down please just
stay away from him stay away I'm
horrible I'm horrible well this one guy
like already pissed off at me because I
I was running in my train and I was
literally like it literally be pulled up
and I had to go underneath the platform
get on the other side to get to the
train and I could I had headphones in
but I could hear someone shouting after
me as I'm running down these stairs to
go underneath he's like just chasing me
and then like like he like for a good
like 20 seconds and I'm currently
running and I'm not running away from
him I'm just trying to get the [__]
train yeah I gotta wait another five
minutes I miss it yeah I was already
late and I'm about to get on the train I
took up my headphones hi and he said can
I take a picture I'm like no I gotta get
on this [__] train she's like oh well
[__] you then no he said that really
yeah yeah I was like okay oh damn yeah I
got a guy that got off the train to take
a photo with me like he was looking I
was on the train going somewhere and he
was sitting opposite and he just kept
staring at me and I was like I hate that
and then I got off and he got off and
he's like oh my God you get a photo so
he like he got off the whole train the
train left and then he had to wait for
the next one I was like wow that's
commitment he was really nice guy now I
love chatting with him so like that's
all that matters but like that went
after me
don't Sprint after me and don't be rude
if clearly you're in a hurry yeah I mean
I was running literally running yeah
like I feel like you just don't stop
people if they're running just feel the
only unbelievable point of that story
was you getting a train Connor yeah
man lives off taxis dude well yeah you
know I'm kind of jumped guilty of
getting too many taxis he's
single-handedly keeping the taxi
companies afloat in this country
I know I know it's bad because some yeah
absolutely my privileges are shy
sometimes I gotta I'll get a taxi I'll
order it to my house and then I'll open
up the the name right and then I'll see
like that I ordered it from the same guy
like four times in the past oh my God
because their name will pop up and it'll
be like tanakasan is your driver today
and I'll see it four times prior they
see your private driver at this point
yeah I should have been like Tanaka man
let's just cut the [__] let's just cut
out the middle man I'll give you 20
squids
what's your what's your private number
hello
stop giving them a cup like
why are we wasting time
um well yeah yeah I I do it a lot
because also I realize that you can also
tax deduct it a lot of the time and it's
I was like all right this is very nice
in the summer absolutely [__] I will
only get the train if it is like so much
more convenient it makes more sense but
if I can avoid it in the summer I'll
just taxi I'd rather I'll just go broke
I'll just lose all my money I just don't
go out in the summer yeah that's just
impossible it's a show I I I wish people
would stop being like it can't be that
bad right I'm like no it is just not fun
I went to I was in Kyoto just for like
the day
uh in the station we only saw I didn't I
think we saw like the ratio was like
like it just is just of like of like uh
foreign looking people but it looked
like the ratio was like three to one
foreigners to Japanese people yeah it
was crazy it was all I'm like why would
you be in Kyoto in the summer it's so
brutal Japan in general I I it's really
not fun I've had some friends come over
recently for something and like I just
can't enjoy it it's like a flame grilled
experience when you step out there are
so many people who come around this time
as well I'm just like you could have
picked any other any other monster some
people come in next month for some
Pokemon stuff oh yeah yeah yeah it's
like why yeah why don't come here in
August that's literally the worst month
because they love Pokemon
awful awful yeah I mean like it's it's
[__] unbearable even as a Southeast
Asian for me as well
because even I don't know how it
compares to like Vietnam when you're in
Vietnam but I don't think Thailand gets
it gets pretty bad but not like this bad
I think it's just because at least the
mega City that Tokyo is obviously
Bangkok is obviously like a huge [__]
city as well but it just traps heat so
[__] yeah Vietnam was kind of like
this in the cities for sure but like if
you're in like small villages it's a
little bit better but yeah yeah that's
the problem especially in Tokyo it's
just like all the concrete just sucks on
the heat it's like Horrible no trees and
it's still the heat radiating yeah yeah
but whereas if you go to like the inaka
or something it's like a couple of
degrees cooler already just because on
the ground I discovered what wet bulb
temperature was this year is that where
your skin doesn't evaporate the sweat
because humidity right yeah I think it's
something to do with a mixture of the
Heat and that can Google just to make
sure I'm not talking about my ass but
essentially like I think it's like at a
certain temperature on the scale like no
amount of water or shade can help you
like it's actually just dangerous to be
outside for extended periods of time
really I think Japan is regular in that
zone oh [__] well it's like man you see
people working in construction you're
like what the [__] like I've got those
weird fans though they're fancy well you
notice that yeah they have the yeah like
two exhausts here and they look like
Michelin men
they have like a permanent Shield
yeah but it's [__] that it's gotten to
that point where like to be outside or
even let me be a walker you have to wear
a fan suit [__] astronauts right here
yeah
yeah it's it's kind of I really I really
want to make that for the next nonsense
piece just the [__] the fan jackets and
the summer dude you need it yeah it's
[__] I mean I just yeah it's it's
absolute suffering main takeaway don't
come here in August yeah July June July
August June's not a super terrible it's
July August July and August yeah June is
also June is mostly just like raining so
it's kind of miserable even September
the start of September Is Not Great yeah
it's pretty rough it's still bearable
though it's still bearable better better
it's the most British conversation ever
yeah over the weather
it is that why it's it's like it's all
you can think about because the moment
you leave your house you feel like
you're on a timer of like death well
yeah I just don't even in here it's
really quite hot yeah this episode is
sponsored by ship station in my life if
there are many things I wish I could
automate laundry food eating everything
but luckily this one thing that we can
actually automate shipping we live in an
increasingly automated world but some
things still require tedious manual work
luckily for e-commerce business owners
shipping is no longer a manual task
thanks to shipstation save time
automating your shipping and returns in
the shipstation dashboard while keeping
costs down with the industry-leading
discount hey I know an e-commerce
business user is right here as Garn
mentioned I own an e-commerce store my
clothing brand and sometimes when we
have to do bulk shipping it's a real
tedious task to manage all of the labels
and the shippings and stuff like that
you'd lose track thankfully ship station
is there for me ship station makes it
easy to automate shipping tasks for
orders from every Marketplace in One
dashboard effortless integration
everywhere you sell online including
Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify and more and with
industry-leading discounts you'll never
worry about overpaying for shipping get
up to 84 off USPS and UPS rate and if
that's not enough use our promo code to
try shipstation free for two months so
my fellow trash taste Hustlers spend
more time growing your own business when
you automate shipping tasks with ship
station go to shipstation.com and use
code trash today to sign up for a free
60-day trial that's shipstation.com code
trash back to the episode so I found out
what the wet bulb temperature means
basically it's like a if a thermometer
that's covered in a cloth that's soaked
in water and it also means that what do
you what are you guys looking at huh
and also it's like the temperature after
like 35 degrees like a certain humidity
your body can't
um sweat enough to cool you down so it's
dangerous and you can just die from like
what heat struggles I think uh whatever
you I don't know dehydration yeah I
guess I don't know damn yeah definitely
I definitely feel Japan is like in that
stage all month basically it's just
[__] hot it's hell on Earth yeah it's
like five minutes outside and I'm like
soaked yeah like I feel gross I I can't
do anything and I just stink I know
you normally
I stink I swear the other day I covered
my entire body in antiperspirant yeah it
stood no chance against Japanese so my
body was like nope the sweat is coming
out we cannot stop I remember when you
went through that phase we're like I'm
not using shampoo
and uh I still don't use much shampoo
your hair was like really ragged and
like [__] off it's like rope
okay it's like carpet I still shouldn't
be like once a week
that's yeah
once or twice a week three in one head
and shoulders every [__] day with
your withered hair
holding on to the remains I have left
[__] you know why is it just a
half-eating piece of Camembert Joey oh
that left that for you Mr camera this is
just this is good I'm stabbing my
Camembert I think this could be a good
YouTube series behind the cheese
boards
but it's a cheese board she's broad now
you've got to try to try the Brie
can you explain what's happening in this
picture
[Laughter]
yeah and uh the price came to this
777 yam and the staff line you were the
chosen one it was said to pray start to
uh are mildly interesting
I'll slash when did I ask
[Laughter]
back in the UK for Christmas
um and whatnot and celebrating the chess
boxing Charlie and I went through a
holiday in the UK yeah and the UK is
actually nice for a holiday sometimes
um but you you don't you don't get that
if you live in the UK you don't right
view the UK through the prism of like us
is a nice country so it was kind of like
nice to go back now and then below it's
good and uh we went to the Lake District
which we went to years before it's kind
of like a special place in the UK and we
went there and it was [__] [__]
because for five days it rained stormed
couldn't literally go out for five days
straight Jesus out of the UK yeah it was
the UK and uh yeah and I was like [__] I
bought the engagement ring I was gonna
do it here it's gonna be a magical
moment yeah and instead we're just stuck
in this like little person's house just
going oh the weather's crap so it's kind
of Tainted my image but anyway I I I
wanted to
kind of Charlotte was like I think the
conversation came up about marriage
because I was kind of like yeah this
will be fun I was like yeah I think like
we went to dinner and I was like I'll
lead her astray I was like yeah marriage
what that rubbish
[Laughter]
bring me another shoes boys what do you
mean I was like that's just rubbish
don't know
if you ever hear me have a conversation
with Charlotte restaurant this is the
quality comp the level of quality you
can expect
[Music]
this is your genius idea yeah
we'll see but I bought the ring a few a
few weeks beforehand down in the UK
shows the ring got the shop and that day
actually when I was getting the Ring
Charlotte was traveling around the town
with her friend and I had to like keep
an eye out while I was in the shop yeah
walk past the window and see me getting
it but anyway I got the ring and um yes
I was like a marriage is rubbish if you
think about it who would want to do that
nonsense and she was like what do you
mean you don't want to you want to get
married I was on I won't think about it
yeah like just like trying to lead her
Australia and we you know they didn't
finish she went back to our room chat
and she got really upset so what do you
want to marry me I was like wow
I was like you don't like marriage you
know I thought we talked about it before
I was like wow
she's a room on the bed she's like upset
crying a little bit I'm like
laughing like a monster
she's like what do you mean you don't
want it and I'm just like
because I'm like the bag's over there
with the ring in it yeah and I'm like oh
if only she knew but I could I can just
be like well guess what good some
wedding rings here's what I made earlier
yeah you can't get engaged even like in
a funny way yeah a memory of the
engagement would just be like trauma to
crying and Trauma like what do you mean
you bought it like it would just be [__]
so I had to like hold off but it was
really uncomfortable and like so we had
like four days of like just off off the
back of that maybe like yeah I'm sure
we'll get married soon don't worry about
it yeah
and then luckily oh yeah we got down to
um Turtle door it's like this rock yeah
yeah good they filmed Tears for Fears
music video there that's why I like it
and then I did it there and she I think
I I put the camera on the um because you
I I do think the engagement thing is
important some people literally just do
it on a sofa like marriage in it and
they're like yeah all right
some people really go like really far
yeah and like doing a [__] hot air
balloon yeah yeah yeah Egypt or
something
I just I'm one in the Middle Ground
Jackie Chan around more than 80 days
what the [__] is this where did you do
it oh I'll let you finish mine yeah but
I I am so I wanted the middle ground I
wanted someone that was a nice location
that was nice and so we've I found
durdle door the wind was like a [__]
hurricane that day
I put the camera down in the um it's in
the rocks
and I was like let's take a selfie she's
like oh yeah okay you took a cell and I
was like all right I've got self timer
five seconds three two one I got Darwin
three two one will you marry me which
was like really I was like yes had it
the whole time and I think she was happy
but it made up for the awful [__] of
making her cry in the Lake District and
it was a nice happy ending it was a
lovely backdrop to it it's a nice memory
now yeah hell yeah about a bit well
um
like it was literally that bad and I'm
an idiot oh it's it's good to know that
I'm not the only one so I think they
always go wrong yeah yeah I'm not the
only one that [__] up his proposal and
it still went right
um so yeah like my idea
for you know the engagement was going to
be like a repeat of our very first date
as we ever did you know so you know like
like romantic yeah like like you how you
were saying some people go super extra I
wanted I'm more like a Sentimental
personal kind of person hot air balloon
no hot air balloons no special no
special things so on our first day we
cycled over we cycled down south Bank
along the Thames and there was this like
picturesque place that we stopped at and
we took one of our first pictures we'd
ever taken on like that first date uh
and I was like this has sentimental
value for me this place is sentiment to
Value so my idea for the engagement was
gonna be we're gonna repeat our first
dates and we're gonna stop at that point
and that's going to be where I do it uh
obviously yeah this one we've been doing
for like seven eight years uh so it's
been a long time since I've been back to
London uh so I was like we were back
just for I guess like a month or
something so I was like honey let's uh
let's let's let's try let's do how do
you feel about repeating our first stay
you know that's that's nice right uh and
honestly the date went really well like
the beginning of the day we cycled down
stopped out all of the places we'd taken
like pictures before and you know it was
all going super well I thought that yes
this is the vibe I was like hoping for
and then we start getting closer to
where this where the engagement point
was meant to be and we start cycling
closer and closer and I started looking
around start seeing uh scaffolding
slowly get of course more and more the
UK
that's weird that wasn't there before
so I started like single single single
sweat drop starts like coming down and
I'm like sure she was just the area
choices sure it's always just the error
no there's nothing to worry about and
then we progressively the date goes on
and as we cycle closer the construction
and the scaffolding progressively get
more and more dense to the point where
that like so this this photogenic area
spot was just kind of like in an area
right next to the Thames like very
picturesque and we got to the entrance
of that area and it was just shut it was
just completely shut all closed off
thanks to construction and at this point
I'm like normally
when I have a plan I have like a plan B
so I'm like go on engineer you can
engineer a plan B and I like cycle
through you I cycle through what my plan
B is and I'm like I don't have a plan B
but what do I do so uh like in a state
of panic I'm like
maybe there's another entrance somewhere
uh and uh Sydney uh Sydney's like yeah
sure let's let's go let's try going uh
find uh another entrance so we cycle
around and this entire area is just
closed off thanks to construction thanks
a lot city of London uh thanks thank you
thank you thank you so much yeah Big Ben
is still no it's good now that's good
it's good now like how many [__]
years half a decade yeah crazy yeah so
we we cycle around the entire area
looking for an entrance but this this
single area is just closed off for
construction so at this point I just
like in my mind I just like given up I
just like all right it's done
this was a good plan maybe I'll try and
find another day and I turn over to
Sydney and you know Sydney knows me very
very well I think she could see how much
I was panicking and I think at this
point she could she could suss what was
going yeah she could suss what was going
on so I look over at Sydney about to say
let's just call it a day for the day and
I look at her and I take a breath and I
and she gives me she she gives me the
most evil eyes I've ever seen Cindy give
me in her life because I think she knows
what I was about to do and she's like
she's bailed she's like no you are not
bailing we are doing this too
I'm sorry I go I'm sorry look turn over
and go
do you want to keep cycling
I'm sorry I was just like maybe God will
smile down on me and maybe there's a
like a nice spot that's not like all
[__] painting and construction so
it's like good boy
she's a good boy uh so yeah we cycled
down for another like 20 minutes and
thankfully thankfully there's like a
place that looks like halfway decent
yeah and you know I set up the camera uh
for for the selfie as uh as you yourself
get the selfie took the video look at
the Twitter engagement yeah and you know
sit and threads yeah Sydney told me
afterwards that of course she knew what
was coming halfway through the day she
could see how much I was panicking but
when the ring came out she just
completely blanked and uh so did I
actually uh because we didn't realize
until after we saw the video
uh that I I didn't realize this because
I like I was just like so shot up with
adrenaline pulled out the ring she was
just like gas for air in shock uh even
though she knew I was coming uh she
didn't even say yes
did she
would never see this she was just like
all right she gospel air she started
crying and I just hugged her and I just
I guess in the moment I I heard yes
please say that was a yes I beg of you
we didn't realize until after we saw the
footage that [__] you didn't actually
say yes in the moment I just hugged you
and assumed you did say yes oh my God
you pull away he's just like no
she's like oh yeah it's like well it's
too late
I never said yes yeah it's one of those
things that you do Panic it's quite a
scary thing you wanted to go right and
yeah you know I I thought she'd say yes
despite making her cry yeah there was a
lot of I was really nervous when I did
it right I think everyone is right when
they go through that yes so I guess so I
don't know I can't really imagine a dude
just being like all calm and collected
being like Yep this is going absolutely
according to playing I'm gonna [__]
nail The Landing everything's gonna go
well that might say beforehand you've
never been in a hot air balloon over
Egypt yeah I mean I haven't but I mean
I'm glad that in a way that it went
wrong because it's just become such a
cool memory for me now
um I think you'd forget it otherwise
you're like oh [__]
oh yeah I have a wife now yeah I just
think your memory regardless yes it's a
core memory but the emotional the
emotional journey I took to get to that
final moment just like Amplified it just
yeah yeah I went through like so many
emotions in those like six hours or how
long that day is otherwise if you if you
if it went smoothly be like it's like
when you beat a video game on a too easy
difficulty I should have should have
experienced in a harder mode I should
have had like a boy trip in front of us
in the picture or something yeah yeah
[Music]
you're gonna like artificial
artificially add like difficulty to your
own case yeah I'll have like a hire like
a bunch of actors
how all of them pull out the ring it's
like which one's the real me
test yeah you can't just uh be married
if you really love me easy to say yes
you've got to prove it you've ripped off
scott
pilgrimsby boss fights Boss music at
least
you
you open up the box it's just an empty
box it's just like the ring is a shitty
Mr B short it's like go to the Bermuda
Triangle and in there you will see what
you seek and it's like just a dead man
shake his hand it's got the ring on it
yeah well congratulations yeah yeah
congratulations lots of congratulations
for you yeah oh book chess boxing
[__] proposal what else do you like
what else you got
no now that you uh have moved
feel about it he never wanted me to move
to Chennai oh really easy for him to get
to take care by playing when I said uh
oh I'm thinking of him to send out Tokyo
who's like Sendai very [__] I was like
all right
um well sir I'll go with a conundrum
though like in the for the book right oh
yeah I've got an audio recording
actually in South Bank
pose and the road works and how do I do
audio recording for three days in a room
for the audio book how the [__] am I
gonna do the voices of people in the
book because I can't be like oh could
you stand this is so good to meet you
I can't like [__] try and do like
impressions are you kidding me I think
your audience will [__] love that I
could see some issues arising but
there's only one voice actor here and
he's called seed of it what Would You Do
Well I voiced the Nigerian archers
myself uh has that said the test of time
no but he'd remove it so uh I would what
you I'll just do your like a a different
voice but not racist
how would I be like
just do it in your own voice just being
like and then natsuki said always
[__] place
yeah you gotta you gotta let the readers
know that the voice has changed it's
scary oh it is no it's fine yeah it's
fine what can I do an American accent I
do an Australian
Accenture I recommend you can't say the
word Umami without doing an American
mommy flavor yeah
it's pretty good for some reason
whatever the word Umami comes into
Chris's diet uh like vocabulary yeah
Umami flavors
why is that I don't [__] know it's
because I saw it on NHK World once right
where they like only hire American
presenters and that's all they say
Umami flavor went to the restaurant and
we had Umami flavors
[Music]
is this uh eighty thousand eighty
thousand words in three days how many
pages
300. yeah yeah that's just it's very
durable
well you have better reading skills than
me was it chapter five
so like for me when I was doing audio
books I didn't [__] know what the
book was about they'd be like and the
elves took their shorts and conquered
and I was like what the [__] is this
[__] that I'm reading like I don't know
what I was reading and you know because
when you do audiobooks as well obviously
you can't read the book and then do it
you read the book well yeah yeah so that
was the hard part I did do a test read
through the other day I was laughing at
my own jokes
that's a good thing that means Chris
laugh at your own jokes yeah I don't
know if that's pretty lame that's good
or maybe not in the recording it's gonna
be like chapter five Mr dick like how
the [__] am I gonna do that
I just want the audio
sound bite yeah I saw the audio
recording of that that's my new text
tone to seven the sausages
September oh wow somebody's getting
real-time editing Latin in the South
Bank
in South America that's where the
recording studio is hello studios in
London okay you didn't think about doing
it in Japan
uh
you probably wouldn't want to do I think
I'm doing it like the day you've got
your show in London
for me come on you'll be like a sellout
show to millions and I'll be in a
recording with being like Mr Dick
there's two dick God is [__] come on our
show wait are you actually going to be
in London during yeah do you want to
come on our show maybe come on come on
what day is it the 9th 9th September 9th
of September I'll be there yeah I got no
special perks yeah if you want yeah all
right on stage yesterday can I throw
throw my hardback books
hey
londoners you get a special guest abroad
in Japan for your show he's confirmed it
he has confirmed it just like my
six-pack it'll definitely happen
get your tickets because uh those are we
still got we still were like a little
bit of like yeah we saw our London
tickets left yeah it's a big venue isn't
it it's our biggest venue you've ever
done Apollo yeah sausages
sausages sorry will there be sausages
will there be Camembert oh you can bring
it on stage yeah just throw Camembert
and sausages into the grass that is the
least flavorful camera I've ever had in
my life yeah it was uh I think we know
who likes cheese like they've still got
two thirds left
Mickey Mouse's closet over here I just I
just had lunch you know it's uh excuse
me it's the finest cheese I could have
fought who wants some more wine oh man
over here I was on YouTube flicking
through like you do which you should
never do
home page
just a dribble of wine for you thanks
yeah I saw a video that triggered me go
on it wasn't even seed OVA
it was white girl speaks Japanese to
Japanese people Japanese people [__]
themselves
I want to know do you ever watch like
I'm gonna guess you don't watch Tick
Tock at all like you don't seem like a
Tick-Tock guy I despise Tick Tock but
you the day that Chris comes after me
and says did you see that thing on Tick
Tock is the day that the world is going
to end
but yeah you uh you might be aware of
like YouTube shorts right
oh
what's your opinion of like the new wave
like YouTube shorts which is like here's
some weird things in Japan number one
top five things that you didn't know
existed in Japan every time I see it I'm
just like I want to buy an island just
live there and [__] turn off the
internet
like when YouTube shots are kicking off
I was speaking to YouTube and they're
like we think it would be really great
Chris if you could do some YouTube
shorts I was like how about [__] off and
uh not you know I know YouTube shorts
for some people and I get it yeah yeah
but I hate them it's not my demographic
I did one on a broader pound one so
people like the [__] is this because my
demographics like a 32 year old white
man in Swindon and like and maybe more
that's it that's the entirely guy the
entire population it could be the David
Attenborough of Japan why demographics
older people when I say older people
like people who are 25 to 35 yeah who
are less Keen to watch shorts yeah I
don't watch shorts I hate them and and
it is literally just did you know
there's a ferry in Japan that you can
ride and it goes across the sea and I
found a vending machine you get pikari
sweat and you [__] yourself and it's
like
[__] time I spend my videos and just
shorts like just crap videos where is
yours annoyance come with the shorts is
it because they're you feel like they're
lower quality or is it because you think
they cover stuff in a superficial way oh
okay nice superficial I don't know just
Japan feels like more more like a
playground for [__] content yeah like
content creators coming over in Spades
now just it's everywhere you know I I
don't want to be like the gatekeeper of
Japan yeah
that's literally the last 10 years I've
spent here yeah every far like a lot far
as I speak to if you want to make a
YouTube Sean Japan you have to go
through me it's literally like top
trumps when you sometimes meet a foreign
right but there are you know people
coming over here
I haven't met anyone yet who has been
here more years so it feels good I have
a tick tock
um and I think this you will actually
get a kick out of this one oh [__] this
had me cringing in a sense that I oh my
god I've never had such I don't mind
shorts for comedy necessarily yeah I
need a quick joke funny yeah but just
boiling down something into seconds it
robs it of any emotional
promoting a product Like A Book Like A
Book Like A Book Like A book
I bought a book I made a book it's just
like yourself so good [__]
does you know there's a book about Japan
that's so good you'll come on yeah
YouTube sure just just be like here's
one weird thing that happened in Japan
or like and you just tell the story it's
a short story and if you want to buy it
you can find out more in my book yeah if
you find out more stories I wrote a book
all of my life in Japan there you go
perfect perfect you can make it in 60
seconds and I never thought I'd see the
day God was trying to sell me on YouTube
shorts
I can't believe my trip to Japan is over
already
I said I can't believe my trip to Japan
is over already
to be fair it is pretty rude to put in
earbuds while someone's trying to talk
to you
well was your trip as adventurous as
mine was there were some new specialty
vending machines I didn't see on my last
trip and it
when you live here you don't look
Japanese and yeah I would know I've seen
several anime that take place in Japan
itself so what the [__] is this
well I bet my knowledge of Japan is
better than yours
hey no backing out of this one you
challenge my knowledge to the greatest
country on Earth so there's no backing
out of this one
I'll start with the first question
question one what is the age of consent
in Japan oh my God no that's actually
not correct because if it was
be in jail right now what is this is
this real like that's a parody it's a
parody
Japan I suppose too much
yeah yeah I've unfortunately met a few
people who are like that yeah well I
think I think some people will comment
as well they're like you guys just don't
[__] hate Japan why are you there and
it's like no no no you know some people
get questions yeah comments like that on
the show oh well it's always that if you
critical of Japan anyway you'll always
get destroyed by someone yeah I mean if
you've been here long enough I think
you'll just have come complaints well
I'm working on a video now to promote
the book a little bit because 10 years
in Japan the good the bad the ugly and
I'm at that scary bit where I'm like
scripting the ugly bit and it's like oh
I've got nothing to talk about that like
you know there's some things you just
don't talk about the issue
it's like the ugly you know so I've got
to tread carefully yeah careful how I do
that well because Japan's problems are
pretty pretty real problems there are
lots of problems I still think the net
on the net yeah
[Applause]
it's because you're you know sometimes I
what I what I do dislike is that
sometimes I'll be like a tick tock show
like these are the top five vetting
machine in Japan the top the first reply
be like why is rape so underreported in
Japan again it's like whoa
these energies aren't matching like it's
like someone who's trying to like on it
like enjoy Japan and then someone who's
like absolutely trying to be like it's a
terrible country the sexual crime is
higher than the US and it's like okay
well I feel so weird as well because
Japan is one of the few countries where
that phenomena happens where it's like
if someone who's a foreigner is like hey
guys by the way I'm moving to Japan
tomorrow yeah and then there's always
that one person that's like you know
that like the sexual crime rate in Japan
is like really [__] and it's like okay
thanks I guess I mean it is but like you
don't you don't but any other country
you don't get that that's what I find
interesting about YouTube shorts and
Tick Tock comments in general yes
because like because Shores and tick
tocks are just reaching an audience that
are like are so vastly bigger than you'd
get on like a stream or like Long
YouTube videos you just see what kind of
comments you'd get if your content would
be recommended to people just like
outside of your own interests yeah right
so it's like you get some of the most
[__] unhinged comments you have like
all the time oh my God I don't like
shorts and tick tocks they're just kind
of crazy sometimes now to see someone
who just gets like an order from
McDonald's and they like 10 million
views because they're just talking about
like shacky tricky it's like it's just
chicken
Shake
short views are worthless yeah both
literally and financially like I was
speaking to someone they got like 10
million views it's like yeah a dollar
it's like wow I mean it sucks because I
I've been very resistant to them for a
long time but I've recently started kind
of trying to do them more because
just the people I just spoke to are like
yeah it's kind of you've got to do it
you've got to do it and also YouTube is
only going to keep incentivizing it more
and more right now it's not maybe not
the best but it's slowly and slowly
they're putting more eggs in that basket
at least they're paying you on like Tick
Tock you know so that's already enough
yeah yeah let's at least one get there
yeah and my short channel gets more
views than all my other channels
combined I know obviously the views is
very different usually yeah like I know
right you know which series but I know a
big uh YouTuber in Japan uh who has
millions of views on shorts and millions
of subscribers as a result yeah on his
main views don't go above like 20 to 50
000 yeah what is the point of that
that's the problem I would much rather
have an audience that's there for the
long form content well a lot more
thoughts generally gone into it yeah
focusing on a topic but you can feel
emotion and try and get something like
Best of Both Worlds you can do both you
can do both and maybe I should explore
it yeah but I'd rather chop my fingers
off
I hate that pressure of having to do
shorts I've had so many people YouTube
and organizations
you need to do shorts it's like no I
don't yeah I just shut the YouTube
channel down and go and [__] read a
book for 10 years honestly my book
that's I'll say all right I hate viewing
YouTube through the prism of business
I've always all I give a [__] about is
trying to make a good video [__]
throw my energy into that video Yeah and
release into the wild yeah
you've got to do YouTube shorts man
you've got to do this you've got to do
that and it's like no I just want to
make a video in it yeah like yeah I hate
that pressure yeah that's ever present I
guess the problem is you just don't know
where the platforms are going a lot of
the times it's very hard to be like oh a
lot of eggs are being put in this basket
more than I had originally anticipated
now I'm [__] because I didn't adapt
and that's always the worry I just hope
you're as excited as I am about reels
Connor reels yeah those are blowing all
by crazy aren't they the [__] is reals
Instagram oh no sorry it's not reels
it's threads or threads we've talked
about threads yeah our threads everyone
threads so they're two days later oh
there's nobody the middle Trends was
interesting it was just like beautiful
like a [__] Falcon known rocket yeah
I mean I would have liked to use threads
more if it didn't share the same problem
with Twitter which is just show me who I
[__] follow yeah please like as soon
as I saw people I don't follow on my
feed I'm like okay no all right this
this actually the other problem was like
I was following people but this wasn't
any stuff on the timeline because people
weren't posting that much and I was like
oh this is
at least on Twitter I see some weird
[__] yeah yeah um you know I I know I'm
getting old because I'm just like I miss
the days where if there is just like a
social media platform where I get to
decide what I see and it's not some
[__] algorithm or some [__]
computer deciding hey this is the thing
that's going to interest you the most
you know because you know for a long
time that was my Twitter that was that
was like my Twitter Twitter was like my
safe space of just my safe space of just
like if I want to follow the people I'm
following and what they're getting up to
this is the space yeah and then Elon
took over and now it's just a [__]
quote retweet hell yeah actually I I
tweets that come up that's just [__]
that I should not be seeing yeah Andrew
Taylor and I don't want to see the
Andrew Tate yeah originally I I was I
was making fun of Chris for buying
Twitter blue and then I looked at my
analytics and it was like it was like it
was like up and down up and down and
then it's crazy it literally took a nose
dive after they removed verification
right and like the Tweet just weren't
being pushed to anywhere I tried to get
rid of Twitter blue after a month and it
wouldn't go away
you [__] bear into your house I
shouldn't have let that bear in I was
like well the only reason for such a
cliff dive was that I lost the
verification and so I joined up again to
see if it go back up and sure enough
right after I bought it again went right
back up I was like this is [__] I mean
that's the only reason I use Twitter is
to sort of promote my videos yeah
because YouTube has become increasingly
[__] so I thought get sort of blue at
least it might promote my stuff and not
know I mean it does unfortunately and
that's the sad truth of the matter yeah
but then you see verified accounts here
like this is useless it's [__] like
Twitter is garbage now yeah absolutely
garbage it's well it's gonna be
worthless in five years I think well
that's why I was hoping like threads
would actually kind of take off too you
know replace it but I think Instagram
you're gonna see Instagram get more
popular yeah oh yeah yeah I've actually
tried doing a little bit I saw [__]
this morning you can't post it a [__]
story and I'm like dad's back
what came in
but like even my YouTube feed uh of
content it's just it's just got really
weird recently it's all very odd and
like unfortunately I'm just getting all
this viral content that I don't want to
see like white person speaks Japanese
people so what are you what is that
[__] content like you can do that
what do you want to watch it yeah I've
put all this time into my video when I
should be going up to Japanese people
going
and they'll go oh no longer does it like
that's not content
this all started from uh what was that
guy who spoke Chinese fluently yeah yeah
which and the thing is is that I think
ultimately the reason why I think
there's those Japanese videos aren't
entertaining from General level is that
I think Chinese people are just way more
shy
in these videos these dudes are like
they'll [__] like flip a table and
Sprint around and go that's true whoa
and then that's why it's kind of but it
doesn't really work in Japan it doesn't
and I I saw a video that like you know
millions millions of years and uh I
clicked I must be good then and it's
literally like oh chicken Tabby Mass
talking
um
[Laughter]
it's just like the Japanese
I was just like if this is the level
what am I doing with my life if I can
get 20 times the views with 500 times
less effort I am doing something wrong
yeah yeah can can we name this episode
like Asian guy surprises two white men
by speaking English for two hours
it's like you know most people they
don't give a [__] they'll say no good
jobs and they'll be gone yeah yeah
that's it and it was a and this video I
saw it so many times come up they've
done I think I know you're talking about
they've done multiple there's a few
people
and it's I'm not even saying it's their
like I'm angry at them because it's the
algorithm that it's the thing about
YouTube you make one video it kicks off
it does really well you want to make
another and I you know I some people
have dead in the life videos some people
have tiny apartment videos some people
have ice white person speaks Japanese
you know and there's this YouTube and
they they go on to one yeah and I've
never done that and I wish I probably
[__] should have done it sounds
sounds like you're more Angry almost at
yourself that you didn't take them
myself
I think it's just like you know what
videos do well about Japan yeah like
when I'm desperate I have like a break
now an emergency and then the Things
fall on the floor it's like okay uh tiny
apartment oh I speak Japanese
you [__] know the content you need to
make but you don't but I just feel like
I don't want it well there's a clip of
me on like Hassan's stream where I
ordered a Starbucks and as you know when
you order a Starbucks hard none of the
words of Japanese yeah yeah they were
like the title was like it's Connor's
amazing Japanese it was like uh
cappuccino
and everyone accounts like what the [__]
but can you say cold brew
coffee and then they were like oh my God
that's the hardest Japanese work to say
yeah
I can't I I just I I when I look at it
I'm like appointed I'm like cool that's
why Connor can't make a Iceberg Japanese
people can you just go to Starbucks and
keep saying like a bunch of just
ordering things until they sound amazing
I don't know I just hate the internet
now
I just think all right yeah I don't know
I'm just better
[Laughter]
I do of course I do still enjoy making
videos there and I love my audience I
love the people that watch I born in
Japan you know there's a really good
core audience I don't know what the
audience is it's probably like 800 000
core viewership that's the most that's a
pretty good if I can make a general I
could make a viral video that I know
would go viral right yeah but I just
want to make the content I want to make
it oh that's what it's all about it
seems like you have a real passion in
like filmmaking I do and I honestly I I
love I get excited about the composition
and the color grading and yeah the least
my least favorite bit is presenting
right right I mean you filmed like a
whole [__] sniper sequence in the uh
journey across Japan yeah that was fun
which you know from a YouTube content
perspective absolutely not necessary
well you know as a content creator I
made that because I want to watch John
Wick 4 and it wasn't that in Japan and
Connor's like oh we're gonna watch
zombie 4 in Hawaii or something and then
I was like that that was what was
powering me through on the cycle well
every day I was like I'm gonna be on
Hawaii next week watching John Wick four
and that was enough to get me so I was
like I can't watch it I'll make my own
job making that skin reuttery and that's
how that came about yeah God said
something the other day he said he said
what he said uh he watched John Wick 4
but didn't watch John Wick 3 and was
like oh it's probably not that important
to the story
I mean it kind of is but you can watch
it without saying I don't I don't think
my viewing experience was diminished
that much by missing uh some of the
stories John Wick doesn't have much of a
story yes it does yeah I mean does does
watching John Wick 3 explain just the
lack of any dialogue that John Wick
actually said John McDonald
yeah
when he says are you pissed John yeah
like it's that strong work I love that
though when he says yes you get the
backstory behind her yeah yeah
it's an interesting month to film I saw
Indiana Jones I'm a big fan of Indiana
Jones
[__] you know wait you watched the new
one yeah I love the original trilogy but
why are you laughing
yes
I mean I mean we should have taken hints
from Kingdom of the crystal skulls right
yeah yeah it's somehow worse than
kingdom of the Crystal Skull really just
watch it uh no I've heard it's way worse
though oh really worse it's just nice
the problem Indiana Jones Indiana Jones
works because Indiana Jones is [__]
cool yeah yeah he gets the girl he goes
in the cave he gets the treasure he's
got a globetrotting adventure and then
Indiana Jones Stars estimates he's just
a depressed man in a room it's this it's
I there's no spoilers but Indiana Jones
is just depressed he's 80. just like
Harrison Ford in real life he's 80 years
old he's in a room going oh the opening
scene of him is flat some people are
playing David Bowie too loud and he's
like
it's like this is not Indiana Jones
where's the adventure this is racist now
racist angry man and like and the
opening they de-age him
I've seen like Star Wars Rogue one yeah
trying to work for a few characters but
like you do become painfully aware like
it in many ways it's the best part of
the film right because the because
James they'd made it in the 90s maybe
yeah yeah um and then the rest is just
like oh I could get the treasure with a
lot of effort in it it's just like if I
did anything we need to get the treasure
but will they be coming there
it's all about like kicking ass and like
getting the girl and like no I think if
you've got a compelling Story the 80
year old thing could work yeah but it
does but it doesn't yeah is it a bad
film no is it a good film no did you
watch the whale
no I just can't I've only seen that one
scene I haven't watched it but I've only
seen that one
yeah where he's like crying I've only
seen that scene I'm pretty sure that's
the only scene of the movie I just I
just wish you'd watch it because I bet
you'd give the funniest review Adam's
the Brendan Frasier yeah oh [__] it just
cries on [__] Skype call me
you can't say that word on it you better
hide that oh you're gonna believe that
one we don't bleeps it yeah
oh dear well yeah India Jane I can't
recommend unfortunately yeah I wasn't
gonna watch it it's better than kingdom
because Kingdom it's just a cluster [__]
it doesn't know what it needs to be and
there's literally Shia LaBeouf Swinging
with monkeys
no it's not it's because you're a monkey
man or whatever did you ever watch um
Shia LaBeouf's like other weird films
like it's an all sorts where
yeah I've seen that oh you have oh [__]
it's [__] it's [__] but it's a
good it's a good week for film you've
got Mission Impossible I watched it
out in Japan yeah watch the at the
premiere where Tom Cruise is supposed to
be but then yeah and uh yeah it's out
now the premiere was I went to the
premiere how'd you do that just bought
tickets online Oh I thought it was like
Tom Cruise's one requests
I bought tickets to go watch the
premiere because I thought [__] it I got
nothing bad to do on a Sunday it's good
uh it's a mission possible
Tom Cruise riding off a bridge it's it's
it's it's you know it's exactly what you
think it's going to be full action
threadbare plot but quite fun I was
gonna I will admit I was a little sleepy
because I was like it's like too much
and the villain is kind of dumb right
right do you really want me to take what
the villain is no I kind of know a
little bit but okay yeah it's kind of
when I introduced it I was like it's AI
yeah I was like okay ai's the bad guy
again okay technology the technology
evil yeah and it's kind of I mean the
stunts were impressive yeah but it kind
of went on like a little too long almost
like two and a half hours yeah I was
like come on yeah you've got Barbie yeah
I was gonna say you seem like gonna be
uh watching Barbie right
yeah people don't know why that is I
think it's because the release date is
close to the Hiroshima bombing
unfortunately you probably like let's
have a film about the bomb and then the
next steps are awesome is you know yeah
yeah so I do get that um I will come out
there I think in September I don't
forget Japan they do have the movies
like [__] six months after they've
been everywhere else yeah but normally
that that's announced ahead of time yeah
it hasn't been announced yet I'll just
watched it in the UK the reviews for
Oppenheimer look good I saw someone go
oh it was great but I had no clue what
anyone was saying just like tenant right
oh great where every Bumble fist every
like Christopher Nolan film it's great
bye yeah
twice at least just to know what the
[__] say it it's like it's like a
cryptic mystery watching a Christopher
Nolan film yeah because he can't [__]
hear what they're saying
and it's like what I had to watch abroad
in Japan
[Music]
just make the audio like good because I
remember like
Batman Begins three Dark Knight what was
it called Dark Knight Rises
Bane was what started it literally had
no idea oh my God Bane half the time
what did you say subtitles are great
yeah
when I watched it with subtitles I was
like oh yeah I love that I love that
opening scene on when he's hijacking the
plane he's just like um the guy's like
no way and he's like yeah
I'm like I don't know what he said I
love him he's just so I've been watching
that and I was a bit close because he's
like what's the next step of your master
plan he's like
it's like I remember going because that
sounds so lame
survivors I know you also watch seeing
or watched silo yeah it's good yeah I
finished it last night start it's really
good I also wanted um Silo what's Silo
so this uh Apple TV show about uh you
just kind of introduced to this Silo
where there's something forbidden relics
so you can't have any old technology and
there's no elevators and you can only go
up this one giant concrete Silo and
everything has to be within the confines
it's big as well as like two thousand
meters is it like an indie kind of movie
no no no no uh production uh it's pretty
good actually oh yeah pretty good last
night the ending is really good to the
first season yeah oh yeah um I watched
Apple have had a good run actually I'm
watching I still haven't watched uh I
really wanted to watch Tetris uh it's
pretty good is it really good it's
really fun yeah Severance watch
Severance Severance is amazing yeah
okay I haven't seen it I should see if
it's good you guys don't watch it
there's like anything good anything good
you guys are like oh sorry I'm watching
too much uh anime stuff and uh playing
catcher games
Jerry's like no no I'm really
I've been watching Severance but I
really struggle to get through this
third and fourth season you're talking
about succession uh six uh yes
all seasons
yeah the opening theme is a banger
though
I'd ride around TK listening to it yeah
yeah I've currently finished like two
seasons of succession and the second one
is good the third one it gets a little
bit Yeah Yeah it all feels good again
Brian Cox carries that show he does he's
very much very intimidating started
watching a new show an apple called
hijack with Idris Elba and it's about a
flame being hijacked well a bit like
just doesn't feel believable the
terrorists are really rubbish
there's five people from Essex and it's
like well we're just playing mate you
better not [__] do anything and it's
just like it doesn't work it's just like
just sounds silly
no that I'm saying people messages
[__] yeah the Apple TV's been crushing
it it's Tetris good yeah it's pretty
good I really want to watch it it's
quite original it's very fun we also did
uh drops of God as well they did a
adaptation of drugs of course I've
watched that I actually we actually
watched it when we visited Napa Valley I
thought it was pretty good uh you know
me um but you had a wide variety of
opinions just because Sydney is just
like it's not like the manga it's not
it's not like the mangas it's not the
real job it's an adaptation it's not
supposed to be exactly yeah there's like
this romance subplot and then like in
the original manga like the two main the
two Rivals are both guys but in the uh
in the adaptation the main character is
a girl and she has like a romance
subplot I'm like it's like a live action
adaptation it's like oh [__] I thought
the adaptation and was actually really
[__] good uh city was just like it's
not the mug it's it's not the real just
read the Manga just read the Manga and
I'm like I like it time you'll have
you're plenty of trying to catch up
because these Rider strikes will yeah
nothing coming out yeah your TV has been
consistently the best over the last few
years to some extent yeah than HBO do
you guys flicks do you guys remember the
last little Rider strike at all well
yeah it was like it was like when you
back in the day oh I was a kid yeah I'd
watch prison break I'm like why is it
[__] yeah 24 you're like Solace right
yeah I've seen Royal Casino Royale best
bomb film ever and it's just like oh
they gave up
stop those uh
terrorist s
yeah I remember when the first Rider
strike happened it was just like you
know as you know you're a lot younger
and I'm just like
sure that I'm sure people can write
stories even though it's not their job I
don't remember it happening I just
remember it happened that all the TV
shows I liked a certain season would
always be bad yeah and then when you go
online and look it was like the writers
strike happened yeah and that was why 24
was 10 episodes less and I was like oh
this is why writers are important yeah
oh okay I get it it's almost like it's a
qualified
like for me it was a song like Heroes
was such a good TV
shows season three I remember watching
season three and this was before this
was back when before like I even had an
inkling of like there were there are
people who made TV shows you know you
know that was like that was like the PV
uh TV period as well it was like lost 24
Prison Break yeah where it felt like
everything was like whoa and then
suddenly every TV show I was watching
got [__] and I was just like what's
what's going on you know what why is
this happening TV fell off yeah did you
watch uh Black Mirror I did I did what
did you think
[Music]
and there's about I would say there's
one absolutely god-awful [__] should be
a mistake episodes no the one with the
wolf the werewolf oh yeah that was like
the worst episode of Black Mirror ever
uh it was so [__] and the extreme Berry
was whatever the other ones I kind of
like the True Crime one was okay because
of the Scottish guy he carried it the
Podrick project from Game of Thrones he
was so fast angry Scottish man he was so
good he was really good he carried the
episode I've seen in a long time and
then the the Aaron Paul was okay but
it's too long yeah I didn't like that
one too long I thought it was trying to
be a lot cleverer than it was just like
it was it was like I felt like it tried
to do the same kind of like twist as uh
what's what's what's the one where he's
uh like being forced to do a bank heist
there's there's no uh I don't something
don't talk to me and dance yeah yeah
yeah sharp and dance
I feel like you've said that line before
yeah I feel like that episode had a
really good [__] setup and a good
payoff and then I feel like it kind of
tried to do something similar where it's
just like oh we have this set up that it
doesn't end the way you think it's gonna
end and it's just I kind of like the
Satan one that was that was the kind of
fun the acting was pretty fun in that
where the devil was so funny in it the
Devils
imagine the devil is just like a guy
who's Charming with a thick British
accent he's like well you do mate you
gotta go and kill him it's a good night
it's so good he's actually that was a
really [__] good performance it was
like a kind of boring premise with
fantastic acting that maybe not to be
like biased but I feel like whenever the
Black Mirror episode was set in the UK I
was like oh this was gonna be a good one
it's true though they're a bit more
grounded in the UK yeah yeah why that is
I I just feel like a lot of this season
of Black Mirror they there's an
interesting idea there but that
interesting idea could cover like 20
minutes at most you know what I mean the
streamberry one was no yeah I didn't
like your [__] Salma Hayek well that
was like that's not a line that needs to
be okay that was like the tradition
because because Black Mirror is kind of
struggling right because it had this
very Tech focused yeah premise and I
guess now they've explored a lot of
options and everyone else is doing it
right is the power black man inspired so
many people to make well everyone
describes stuff as black mirroresque
right we have anything's dystopian
technology I was like oh it's very black
mirror-esque
yeah she's just walking around with the
cameras black mirrors I would also argue
that reality has kind of caught up to
Black mirror as well in some way where a
lot of these out there ideas that
happened when season one started airing
uh reality is kind of caught up and
we've realized oh it's actually happened
just a documentary yeah episode one
where the Prime Minister [__] a pig
yeah
allegedly he was reported David Cameron
did something with a pig
[Music]
in the UK allegedly uh I think there's
there's more ways that you can explore
that feeling of
feeling trapped online with twists and
stuff and feeling like online is kind of
beholden and you're kind of being
trapped by it there's more ways to
explore that I think that they've just
it I feel like it's probably given up I
just feel like it's dumbed down for a
younger audience a little bit Yeah
guys just you know make it a bit more
like you know accessible to younger
people the True Crime one I felt
actually could have been quite good
exploring True Crime and the obsession
of it but I felt like they kind of were
like all right now let's just do a twist
and it's kind of fun there's a sorry
that's fine I was gonna watch it I just
felt like it because True Crime is
actually such a prevalent thing and
you've never been a fun poignant way to
talk about it in a black mirror-esque
way that kind of didn't feel like
they're nailed it didn't make you sit
down and watch true crime documentaries
like the man that killed his entire
family I just I I don't she doesn't make
me sit down makes me like well she
doesn't make me but she's like I'm gonna
watch the documentary about everyone
that killed them I just I just wake up
and like she's she's doing on roses
she's doing her makeup and I'm just like
getting ready for the day and uh his
arms were caught off ground by his dad
his legs were cut off and Timothy found
her uh his dead parents and called 9-1-1
here is the call and it's just to keep
going
[Music]
and I'm [__] side hearing
a good report his dead parents did you
see that YouTuber that a Charged money
to see an 11 year old boys autops oh yes
I did see that news because I guess True
Crime is going so commodified now yeah
what they had I guess people are like
because obviously I think a lot of the
historical cases have already been well
documented so now it's getting to the
point where they're covering like stuff
as it's happening which is kind of
[__] because like yeah yeah these
people were inserting themselves in like
the process essentially and were like
turning up to the the hearings and
getting the information they're just
immediately posting about it and it's
like it's pretty [__] like it's just
it's getting to this state now where
like True Crime is just it's just like a
reality TV show of what's happening and
then now they're showing the [__]
morbid stuff because we have these
systems of accountability where people
would have to release information to the
public and now it's kind of being abused
in a way where it's like turning it into
circus shows and freak shows it's like
if you want the HD photos of a dead body
go to my patreon and pay 15 in dollars
it's like that's far so [__] up it's
so funny I mean I mean that's part of
the reason why I was never really into
true crime in the first place yeah it
talks about True Crime before I was
talking about the same time because I
think it's an uncomfortable topic yeah
and you know ever since the first
episode we've talked about it on trash
taste the line has just got and been
pushed more and more yeah and you know
you know going back to Black Mirror I
think part of the reason why Black
Mirror isn't doesn't hit as hard now
it's just because reality is caught up
online is way scarier than when it was
at the first season where in the first
season we can view like the stories of
black mirrors like look at this funny
thing and now we look now we look at the
late season of Black Mirror and we're
like actually reality is [__] weirder
more depressing you know on the next
season there'll be one basically like
ripping off the Apple Pro Vision they'll
just make one her dad who sees this kid
that isn't there and he imagines he's
still there even after the death of his
kid and he goes crazy and it's eternally
fused to his face so he can't take it I
genuinely think like they've become so
shallow that it's so easy to kind of
just write a yeah predict a Black Mirror
episode yeah just hate walking into my
sitting room and hearing when we got
there there was blood everywhere I
couldn't stop the bleeding and what have
you done today in his face and I'm just
like I'm having a nice morning
put the headphones in or something yeah
like the man that murdered his entire
family for seemingly no reason yeah what
no it must have been a reason let's look
at some stuff that's really like you
know they you have that level of
distance but sometimes they show some
stuff or talk about some stuff like this
feels like you shouldn't be allowed to
view a public knowledge yeah this feels
like really [__] feels really invasive
right now yeah yeah yeah what a great
uplifting topic to end this podcast I've
got Aquarius and a wine glass nobody's
ever done that before wow five weirdest
things to do in Japan
Aquarius in a wine glass
that was your vending machine downstairs
the only real problem I have with the
tick tocks covering Japan this is just
flat out spreading wrong takes about
some of the food establishments they'll
be like
don't go to McDonald's go to Mossberg
it's like yeah it's like well no Moss
Burger is just worse than McDonald's in
Japan it's just also takes five times
longer to come five times longer than
the nuggets are the only thing that is
slightly better because they use like
better chicken but everything else is
worse yeah oh yeah yeah but like there's
some other stuff as well where they're
all like oh if you're in Japan and
you're on vacation don't don't go to a
restaurant go to the Family Mart in
order to get this microwave pasta it's
like no don't come to the Japan and get
microwave food you have the good stuff
it's cheap it's just the image of
Japan's gonna be one where everything's
crazy and ridiculous the shorts I see
it's always a really wacky or wild [__]
yeah saw one that got pushed to me the
other day with like a trillion views and
it's like I went to Japan's Teddy Bear
Cafe and there's like a [__] hole in
the wall and a pool comes out oh yeah
yeah
part of the problem actually God damn it
there's more to Japan than rare poor
teddy bear restaurants probably well I
just feel like Japan as a country is
just tailor made for
helps me get video ideas and sometimes
Cara gives me some ideas that are like a
bit a bit much and uh
one time having a conversation with Carl
she's like hey um so I have this video
idea and I'm like all right cool what
what's that so you know there's a lot of
services for men out there
um and I found one where it's for women
I was like oh okay cool like what chick
well you know there's a lot of services
where men can get pleasured but I found
a place where uh women will get
pleasured and I was like
okay so how do I what what am I what am
I filming she's like well it's a massage
place but at the end the guy makes you
come and I was like how how do I film
this and she's like and I think the guy
will let you join in if you want I was
like I'm okay with not doing that yeah
and then um so I was like I'll I'll pass
but uh another guy going to it is what
you're saying or you going to and you're
using as a server so I would go there
and film and then apparently the
customer would be okay with letting
whoever the presenter is do the thing
it's a Conor dog video waiting that's
just you're just a porn director
yeah it's like it was and then so I I
said I'm I can't film that yeah for
obvious reasons yeah uh but I appreciate
the offer go and it has a great sport
about it it's very funny I'm like I'm
like cow tell me every idea let's just
go and you know I'd rather you bring me
the weird ideas and say no than not tell
me yeah yeah yeah but uh someone else
did take up take up on the offer and I
had a chance to speak to him and he's
like yeah it's a bit awkward just sat in
the corner of a room commentating while
one got finger blasted and then
afterwards afterwards she offered to let
him do it and he was like I'm okay and
then apparently her husband was just
okay with it or didn't really fully
understand what was happening right I
was like but she was okay being on
camera yeah yeah it's kind of weird and
I was like all right you sound like a
brothel in Disguise what that's a half
in Japan yeah that's exactly yeah are
you kidding me Japan has so many
brothels that are just hidden in plain
sight they're just there it's insane
it's actually getting even the [__]
Pub that we go to you look across the
road they're like [__] flashing Neons
and jobs ten dollars and it's like in
the bar and it comes they're not even
inconspicious about it there's like 80
000 LEDs on that bill it's crazy it's
like the most well littered place in
Yokohama I've seen so many lights in
anywhere so it's just like and it's in
English they've got English menu Animas
well I don't think any content I'll be
making on top of that yeah no that's so
hard I've got to make sure the only
[__] times we're like when is that
happening
okay we're ready I'm ready for the plane
launch into a volcano what are we
skydiving
all right do you want us guys
I'll do take for guns I couldn't get him
to go on a [__] children's
that was a big gorgeous
but they're looking down 200 meters this
snaps it's a quick game yeah ggs but
like rather than make take actually make
take of a guy and I thought we were
really funny to make like a trailer for
take the guide okay then you can have
all these action-packed moments where
it's just like you know you're walking
home from trash taste then you get like
kidnapped and waterboarded or something
it's a fantasy I have so you wanna you
just wanna it's gone from like [__]
bungee jumping foot to that just like
torture yeah I just want to make a snuff
film with you
I just want to make content about all of
the films that you feel or you have just
watched
well Indiana Jones
it makes no sense it's like I just
wanted to show off this cool thing if I
was gonna DH God just have a shave watch
Oppenheimer then
well I I want to do that I want to do it
for like April fools all right um I was
gonna make a uh like a Netflix quite
true crime thing about trash day it's
called I think I told you last time
bitter taste yeah I was gonna be like
they invited me on a trip
you have a friendly Scottish character
now who's really well active really
angry for sure sure it's great but
that's my girl I mean yeah let's do it
hit me up yo you're in Tokyo now in
Tokyo I have a question yeah
um you when we were on the cycle you
every single day you'd be like I can't
wait to play Resident Evil full remake
and you every day you'd be like I've
heard it everyone's saying it's the best
thing ever made uh did you play it
play for half an hour pizza
it was good yeah graphically great a lot
of effort though in it it was like find
the key I was like oh [__] you know
I've never seen you talk about a game
and you're being excited for it and I
like strategy games where I could sit
there with a like a pie and just sort of
move like oh I have a tank over there
this I mean chess yeah like I could just
sit slowly digest a pile of food
have all the soldiers die Age of Empires
yeah civilization anything like that
there isn't evil people to your to their
death
go on man well he's my camera bear I'm
surprised you've brought up the fact I
listened to Joseph Stalin yeah you did
well so we're on the cycle and we're
very tough and Chris for the first two
days was very like hey guys what's up
and then and then I think it got so
difficult it was very tough it was so
much harder than Hokkaido yeah and there
was a lot of rain there's a lot of rain
it's miserable and then after the we had
the the third and fourth days was hell
and then after that Chris Chris was like
a hikingomori on his style and audio
books it was like it was like we didn't
hear from Chris for the next four days
he was just cycle and then occasionally
apparently because his phone was
connected to the car when he was cycled
closely to the car the Stalin audiobook
would start playing in the car
and it'd be like it would like be put on
pizza he'd be like well so guys we're
gonna go and he'd be like Stalin
murdered 15
000 people because they dropped his
handkerchief on the floor and it was
just like what is he doing what is he
what is motivating this man to cycle
what is this reason I I was listening to
start Stalin's toils and ups and downs I
thought why why
he's like for most of his life Stanley
was like living in what made you want to
listen to all of this on the cycle pods
I thought he's had a rough rough time
well I'm making stuff nice yeah
before he became the the lead the
Undisputed [__] Paramount leader of
Russia he was in like prison camps in
Siberia for 20 years all right and I was
listening to that thinking if he could
do that I can get through today's cycle
that's like my thought process but then
it just got really Bleak Because by the
second after book when he becomes
powerful he's just like if his friend
says something he doesn't like he's like
yeah
Stalin killed his friend David and like
every every [__] page one of his
friends is just being sent off to a
concentration camp whatever Jesus Christ
just like this isn't this isn't fun but
it's still more fun than this [__]
psycho you didn't like it the weather
was bad the weather was the terrain was
brutal like the hokkaido's like if you
ever want to cycle where we do Hokkaido
like that's great yeah beautiful city it
was tough it was stunning
we regularly had four or 500 meters and
we had a 700 one day check back the
video of this one Hill That Never Ends
it took we were walking 40 minutes on a
vertical Hill yeah I remember that hill
so distinctly it's just never ended that
was pain that was true suffering but not
as bad as Stalin there's people yeah not
as bad as what Stalin did
um but that was Wireless to that I think
I needed to get through it
my mind
I just needed something I need some I
don't know I I had I had a playlist of
uh songs I would listen to before I go
like I went on stage just to hide me up
yeah like a lot of like Carpenter brute
just to be like let's just get the
adrenaline run it yeah you know I I
started every day cycle with listening
to music the one song I always used was
uh Boogie Wonderland my Earth went on
fire
that is the start of a great day and I'm
like yeah it's so happy now there's a
boyfriend though he did not interact
with Chris for the first two hours of
the morning until he's fully woken up I
need the whole Earth Wind and Fire album
yeah
that was a tough one I think we'll
definitely change some things to the
next one yeah e-bikes
a motorcycle just get a moped just get a
moped yeah because like we picked the
time where it should have where it like
didn't rain much and it was just we just
got [__] by some weird rainstorm that
come from the south it was horrific it
was horrible that one day because you're
hot and sweating like this temperature
now but you've got rain mixing with the
sweat so you thought you're drowning
especially when you've got your gear on
you're cycling yeah you have to really
go to a very special place to get
through that you have to take a holy
stalini seal people are donating me like
oh yes this reminds me of my Navy SEAL
trailer I'm like what the [__] I'm just
trying to cycle he's like yeah it feels
awful but you have to just keep going I
was like oh my God you know what got me
through a Stalin audiobook [__] because
there's no part of your body that's
comfortable in that it was like it was
like you know you fell off twice I fell
off twice as well that was just
miserable and that looked painful yeah
my leg was awesome
yeah this is so nice he's cheering Conor
up because I was
Miserables yeah you were like you look
like you were going to stop or just
implode well because like I think any
sane person doing that who wasn't on
camera would just call it a day there
and I think it just wouldn't you'd see
that level of rain and you'd be like no
well we're not doing this yeah because
it was the kind of rain where
you know if it drizzles or rains
normally you you get a little bit wet
maybe your hair gets wet your clothes
get a little bit damp but your shoes
aren't like water locked and you're not
like soaked and because you know you're
moving you know it's it's constantly
there but that was the kind of rain
where I just I remember I remember so
distinctly there was this bridge that we
started do you remember this bridge it's
a really long bridge about a kilometer
long and I remember we started because
it's the start of the bridge was the
start and by the end of this bridge I
was completely soaked was soaked they
were fully like waterlogged you get
every single worst thing that yeah every
single part of the body it was 10
minutes in it was already like your
Feet's in the river tent and then your
your glasses your you can't [__] see
anything because you're you know you've
got water on your glasses or it's just
like everything's miserable and then the
worst part I don't know if you if you
remember this but I I got really cold I
started getting really really cold uh
towards the end of the day at the point
where I was like shivering for like the
past two hours and I was like I don't
know what to do because I can't get warm
because to get warm I need to dry and
there was a point drying when I'm going
to threaten to piss yourself to get warm
I was I was I was actually this close
away from pissing myself because I was
so cold right I know it was it was to
the point where I thought I was cold
where I was like I think I would have
bad Health consequences if I was out for
like another two hours yeah yeah yeah
and I think we had 20 kilometers left
where I was really feeling faint I was
like let's just do it let's just finish
this I'm being I thought you meant let's
just piss yourself
I was desperate so I was like I gotta do
something and I remember being in the
McDonald's afterwards just depressed
because I was so I was still obviously
even when you when you've been cold for
like a few hours yeah uh even if you
change clothes and get warm it's kind of
weird your body doesn't quite heat up as
fast
yeah yeah it was kind of weird because I
was just in this McDonald's feeling like
[__] and then I was just but Chris was
full of joy because Chris was I I
remember I remember the menu came out
and you were like well then it was a
good day it wasn't that bad that day and
I was like
oh
and I just felt like [__] because we
were also McDonald's and there you got
the wrong Burger
and then they [__] up my order that
was last day but they also [__] up my
order that day as well it was not good I
can't hear you sorry Christopher Nolan
film
what does he saying yeah I ordered on
the [__] app but yeah that was that
was a grueling one I think we're going
to change a few things the next one
these are the moments that define the
year it's true
I'll never forget
oh yeah I know
suffering suffering is what you remember
a lot well it's not like type 2 fun
right type two fun it's fun where you
look back on when you look backwards fun
in the moment it's not it's not fun at
the moment but then when you look back
on it you're like that was fun who named
it type two I don't that's quite good
because it's easy to look back
he's got type 2 How often have you done
something that you remember to send me
my [__] right and then you look back on
it and you're like that was fun you're
like no no Connor don't don't lull
yourself into thinking that was fun
the idea of it again was fun and the
highlights were fun but it was [__] yeah
good to see you on your cycle like next
cycle fun it's like I'm having such type
2 fun right now
[__] house I mean it was all worth it
to CP on a bike for five seconds yes I
can do it I believe that was so good did
well for the you second one like 10
kilometers she's pretty good was the
less I didn't need to do so I was very
happy yeah life just a bunch of memories
it is yeah the weeks where I'm just
setting doors doing the same [__] the
ones you forget it's when you get out
and put yourself through hell that you
remember it right absolutely all right
well that's been this episode of trash
taste hope you enjoyed it take it away
Joe hey look at all these patrons though
you see the more first point to one oh
look at that one bought my book did he
yeah
oh my God hey if you want to buy Chris's
book then we'll leave that in the
description and uh also follow us on
patreon at patreon.com trash taste I
might see you guys in the UK yeah hell
yeah come to our live show in the London
guys available on trash tastetour23.com
I'll be going also follow us on Twitter
say this memes on the subreddit and if
you had a faceless to us on Spotify and
uh well we'll see Chris again sometime
in about nine months oh is it always a
pleasure to see you guys
VA warming technique now all right see
you guys next week bye
foreign
[Music]